all right and we are live the last word
with lor cognito and ivantes and ty guy
travis fresh on that thursday evening
campfire gentlemen how we doing start
with ivantas himself lead developer in
the middle high resolution character
boss fighting for those of you guys that
are getting the audio version of this
they're talking about the video version
we are live on youtube so if you guys do
catch this on spotify on itunes for one
drop us a like if you enjoyed the show
but come check out the video there's
usually some interesting facial
expressions that tend to happen but yeah
apparently i'm sitting in the middle of
these two so i'm like you know kind of
playing referee they also have dark
shirts on and i got the light shirt so
i'm like ref right now your white shirt
makes you look like you're bigger and
yeah you look like a threatening boss
with big arms and i'm like i'm like
you're not looking for people i look
like i have a small head and a blow up
suit on right now like the mixture a
little bit
i was good
um what's going on no just uh had a
pretty quiet new years with my wife
didn't really go anywhere
uh we watched the harry potter 20th
anniversary thing on hbo the next day
just to kind of go back through that
world
so
i've watched those movies like cycled
through them every few years we'll go
through all of them but
that was pretty good um but in the last
few days and
trying to figure out what to start the
new year i've actually been playing
inscription
a game i never thought i would play
because
so
i liked uh there's another podcast to
listen to is play watch listen it's
alana pierce travis or looking at travis
and saying it yeah you
no it's mike bithell austin wintery and
then who's the main voice actor i'm
forgetting here
last of us voice actor big guy
i don't know that guy uh starts with a
team yeah i know that's why i said
travis troy baker thank you troy baker
yeah maker so it's all for them and they
always like they'll title the episode
one thing and they'll always fall off on
tangents it's just always kind of cool
to hear their different histories and
stuff that they've had um but she had
actually been raving about inscription
but really never got to talk about it
that much and then i saw it keep kind of
popping up in places on
um game of the year list and i was like
what is this game it was on ign's list
yeah and it was like
solve raves about it yeah and i was like
and i look at him like it looks like
this weird old and it's devolver digital
so you know they got their kind of
stylistic stuff um and it's this weird
creepy
card game and the way alana basically
described it was like it's a card game
until it's not and i'm like
what does that mean
and then you start playing and i'm like
and i don't do like deck building card
this is not like my genre of game like
at all like i've heard people play like
yu-gi-oh and like you know do peop at
this point people talk yeah people do
pokemon cards just to see if they get a
good one but they don't play that i mean
i played magic gathering
years ago a little bit like when i was
younger i gathered some cards played a
little bit but it's been forever so i'm
getting this thing i'm like okay first
you kind of understand the mechanics
and you're going through and it's just
basically a card game
you'll go through and you know the first
time you go through you're probably not
going to win
and then
your next round and this won't be too
much of a spoiler basically it's gonna
say you can stand up from the table and
that's all i'm gonna say and i'm like
okay
okay
and then it just kind of goes and then
last night
those who were watching me on stream
this thing took a hard like
left u-turn j it went such a weird
direction everybody like there was one
of the guys in chat was like i have to
go to sleep but i cannot peel my eyes
from the screen it is so
so weird yeah teddy calm down yu-gi-oh
is not here in the discussion tonight
because i'm clueless about that you need
to go talk to drew scott anything about
yu-gi-oh yeah allow me to speak about it
but yeah it's like so i got to
another part basically i got i got to
another section and it has taken an
interesting turn so i will a game that i
didn't think i was going to start
playing and i was like i'll just see if
this like sticks because there's like i
bought some other stuff on steam for the
steam sale
i i actually kind of want to see where
this one goes and i did not think this
was going to be a game for me and like
cards deck but not
like gwent and other stuff in games i
could probably care less but like for
some reason this was like
weirdly in yeah yeah nathan was there
last night i remember that he was like
he got four hours of sleep he's like
last night was insane it was and i don't
want to spoil it because
if you get there
and you don't hear about it before you
get there
you're going i'm sorry what's happening
that's i don't know so i know i'm being
extremely vague and not helpful to
anyone but
if you see this game
and it has any intrigue to you at all
stick with it because it actually seems
like it's going some cool places that's
all i'll say um but that's been outside
of destiny grinding and other stuff
going on um that's kind of been my start
of the new year for my first game but
yeah finished up a couple before the end
of the year but we talked about those
but yeah that's my new one for 2022
amongst my giant backlog travis what
about you what have you been doing
catching up on
yeah destiny taking a break yeah so i um
no i i've been playing some destiny uh
my big project is that before
february 22nd comes around i have to get
the catalyst for the forerunner pistol
right
um
and that means i have to do five dares a
day
until february 22nd
so i have an alarm i have a daily alarm
that reminds me to log into destiny and
play five dares
and so that that that is actually
starting today or tomorrow um but i i
have to there's certain things i have to
get done
and usually i don't care as much but
with this one i care because a major
expansion is going to come out when i'm
not going to have time to do this right
yeah yeah whatever whatever other per
weather way they give to to give that
catalyst i'm not going to have time to
do it if i don't do it now so i need to
do it now so that's on my destiny
checklist everything else is done i did
the damn donning i got all the cookies
baked
i really i really hated it this year it
was like especially obnoxious um but
yeah i got that done over the break
and then i on the very last day of the
year
i completed my goal of beating every
game that got nominated for oh wow
yeah i saw you playing literally
psychonauts two literally was that one
of your last two i the rolled credits on
it 100 completion of that game on
new year's eve like it was like six
hours before the new year wow wow so
yeah i was happy about that but i
actually um i ended up having enough
time because
uh a lot of games didn't get nominated i
ended up having enough time
to actually go back and play psychonauts
one and i 100 percent of that i saw you
right
now
wow yeah and that game it was
unbelievable because that game came out
almost 20 years ago yeah it was in 2005
i think original xbox yep and um
what's crazy is that with the with the
xbox backwards compatibility
the frame rate runs like crazy the all
of the old textures have been sort of
like smoothed over so it's really not
that bad like if you were playing on an
old xbox i feel like it would hurt you
but playing it on the xbox series i was
playing on series s because i wasn't at
my house i was on my portable xbox
absolutely but playing it on the series
s like
it it felt like not that old of a game
and then when i jumped into psychonauts
2 the first thing i noticed was how
little they've changed psychonauts 2
is almost identical to psychonauts 1
philosophically like it's crazy how
little they change like it's it's really
insane um yeah i really like that game
um
i liked uh forgotten city i liked a
bunch of other guys i ended up catching
up on um but yeah i played
all of the games of consequence that
came out last year uh which i'm very
happy about and uh now i'm off to the
races i got my first three reviews
assigned to damn for ign
yep right now i'm reviewing a game
called wind jammers 2 that is a sequel
to a 1994 snes game win
jammer so okay random jammers funny
thing um
yeah when we went on a car we went on a
cruise
i don't know four or five years ago and
that was actually a reasonable thing to
do
um
not right now not now uh
there was it was there was like the
dining hall that you'd have for like
your two dining times like you know
you're 5 30 8 o'clock and then there was
like the cafe that was open most of the
day
and like you go in the dining hall and
people would dress reasonably and not
like complete flip-flops and garbage
then you would go into the cafe and it
would be who knows what tank tops
whatever like just a complete mess of
people in there in the cruise ship and
it was the windjammers cafe
so it was always like a joke when we
were like joking around that you'd be
like going it's like all those
windjammers or something it was like a
weird joking
like
derogatory word that we had for just
like
trashy people just like the windjammer
just just started waiting
yeah
whatever yeah
so just like when you said windjammers
was like that's the only thing that
comes in the market
yeah so i actually missed when jammers
won i was i was five years old when that
game came out so i guess that's not
terribly surprising that i missed it um
but yeah i didn't play that game but
when i found out i was reviewing it i
went back and i bought when jammers won
for this for the switch um the old game
and i played through that entire game
and uh it's actually pretty fun it's
basically like um like pong right like
you're throwing a frisbee back and forth
and it's on kind of like a tennis court
and you're trying to bounce it off the
walls and get it behind the person
that's guarding their their uh their
goal and and so it's it's kind of like
playing air hockey actually it really
reminds me of i got it hockey okay um
yeah and windjammers two basically just
takes that formula and they add a bunch
of crazy powers and other stuff where
you can do like crazy moves and you can
like spike it on people and um you know
it's kind of like an over-the-top um
game of air hockey um and i'm liking it
so far cool um and then i'm also i also
found out i'm reviewing crossfire x oh
that's my next review there you go i
want to know about that yeah
on february 10
and then come february 22nd i will be
reviewing destiny 2 the witchcraft
so that's my first three reviews uh for
this year
that i'm working on so nice times
great
so i was like i know you did
uh was it beyond light that you reviewed
was that was that you i've reviewed
every destiny dlc since shadow keep okay
uh so did shadow keep and beyond light
both for expansions
correct nice
um so i'm curious how long hours-wise
would you say
it takes for do you expect something
like a crossfire review
versus say obviously like a live service
destiny review what is the difference in
hours that it takes between say those
two because crossfire is that's the
campaign part mostly
yeah i think i'm reviewing both i think
it'll be online campaign but usually if
it's like a game where you're just going
in and doing pvp matches like halo
infinite multiplayer yeah ign's rule is
that is that generally speaking you have
to have played at least 10 hours of the
online portion so and then for the
campaign you always have to complete the
campaign so the thing i've learned about
reviews at ign is that there is
absolutely no consistency with how long
a review is going to take
some games like gentian impact i played
120 hours in a while like i was just
playing that game
every second like every
minute jesus yeah basically basically i
think i slept like three hour nights
because i was i was really trying to get
that review done because it was a
fantastic game and nobody was talking
about it and i was just like i need to
like finish this as quickly as possible
um and then other times i'll get a
review like windjammers2 is kind of
example of this where like i played it
and after five hours i'd beaten the
campaign with every character and i was
like okay i i feel like i'm kind of
ready to start writing already
so it kind of just depends but destiny
reviews typically take
a week and a half of me playing every
day um
so yeah it's definitely
more similar to genshin impact than to
uh other reviews live service games take
an extraordinary amount of time yeah and
the bad thing is that you also can't
um
you can't play it in advance which is
right right exactly it was the same
it was the same problem with gentian
impact where i was playing it when the
game was already out but with destiny
i'll be playing along with the rest of
you guys and typically i don't start
writing my review until i've played the
raid so assuming that we follow kind of
the history protocols 10 days yeah yeah
yeah i i will be playing destiny every
day every hour of every day for the
first 10 days that it's out and then
after i'm done with the raid assuming
that all the content that is expected is
done i just go heads down into writing
the review and doing the video and all
that stuff and then get my review out
the door as quickly as possible
i don't typically do a review in
progress some people do that but for
destiny i just don't find it super
useful
for me to write a review in progress
because i'm just telling everybody what
they already know if they're playing it
and if they're not playing it they can
wait a couple extra days for the raid to
be out and that sort of stuff so don't
respect that um i don't i don't
typically do review and progress but
yeah uh i'm very excited about all three
of these reviews starting off with
something that's a little shorter and
then crossfire is probably going to be
meaty and the destiny is going to make
me wish i was never born
so what are your previous scores on
shadow keep and beyond light
so both of those reviews were written
let me check actually i don't think
that's true so my first review was
written when we were on a 100 point
scale with ign which was terrible by the
way 100 point scale is like completely
useless like six point what's the
difference between like
yeah what's the difference between like
a 7.8 and a 7.7 like how is that helpful
to the reader to know by that so i
actually i'm a huge supporter of the
10-point scale because i think it makes
sense like a 7-8 is very clear what the
difference is we have orders that
associate with those um but my review of
shadow keep i think was a 7.8
which is at ign is a 7 is a good is good
if we were on a 10 point scale i would
have removed the 0.8 and just made it a
7. okay and then i think um
i think beyond light was
basically the same thing it was kind of
around the same it might have been an
eight uh but yeah it wasn't i've i've
never given a
destiny review score higher than than
that it's like around a seven or an
eight okay which let's be honest that's
like mostly what destiny content is
right it's usually like good or great
but it's very rare that it's like
amazing like i i probably would have
given forsaken a nine don't have taken
king and nine uh
you know i didn't review those ones
that is fair
um yeah from for me yeah yeah what even
definitely oh yeah what are you guys
what are you guys doing mr meadow you
were reviewing destiny what do you think
what do you think uh the uh witch queen
will score for you we're gonna get into
that man i was like put a pin in that
because i want that actually discussion
yeah that's a good discussion yeah we
definitely gotta do that next um for me
game wise obviously like e was talking
about um i i've been indoctrinated with
the crash so i've been really getting my
feet wet but i have to admit like you
were talking about you with this car
stuff this game called demeo i am like
thoroughly addicted it is like this one
so basically it's like cpr game yeah
it's it's cool dungeons and dragons
meets diablo
meets like x-com a little bit and like
i'm gonna be really like i'm not a
dungeons and dragons guy like i've never
played i got friends that played at a
hardcore
let me tell you man this game is fine
this game is amazing like i am
thoroughly addicted you can manipulate
the board you have the the traditional
tropes you know the the knight the the
thief the mage you know that kind of
stuff they got a new character class but
it's so good that what i like about it
is that
it is very challenging you really have
to work with your teammates and and
everything counts and then the other
thing about it it's kind of funny
because it's like
you actually are manipulating the pieces
like chess pieces on a board and you're
moving them over two spaces and do it
and that part you're doing your virtual
alley and like kind of maneuvering the
board it is really impressive
like yeah the vr space is basically like
you would be sitting over the table you
could turn on the table over a table
yeah and then you can reach in and grab
and move yeah grab the pieces
like the background is like somebody's
basement in the in the 80s it's
hilarious it's like you're playing
dungeons and dragons in someone's
basement but it's really really cool but
um so i've been rocking that and then
it's doing so well it's like it was like
rated uh vr is like one of the vr's top
games of 2021
and they're coming out with a steam
version in april nice they're gonna have
full cross play i already have the steam
version oh oh oh
i think i think it's out because i i
have it i haven't i haven't turned it on
yet but i have okay i didn't even know
if it was out but i just know for this
game is amazing so i've been blazing
that i'm playing a lot of that um as far
as uh like uh travis was saying with
infinite the ten ride event came back so
you know the ninja got to get his
samurai stuff on they actually added
cosmetics they actually added bounties
every day that contribute to the special
event so salute to 343 for doing that
i've been rocking that and then for
destiny it's just been a lot of homework
so got my obviously got the galley got
shout out to dj he's in there um he's in
an easy to chat right now we rocked out
we did a grasp i want i got to get my
cat right now my homework is getting my
catalyst done
i got to get galley catalyst done i got
to do what she's doing try i got to get
my 4runner catalyst and um i got our
bullets
catalyst i got armless catalyst to drop
so i gotta work with her
oh no arby is like i don't wanna take it
off i mean for the rest of the season
because right now linears are good but
even when it's not just the fact that
the single shot can break any type of
shield yes and it's also an intrinsic
barrier weapon like to me it's
not quite as much ammo but it's usually
a single shot for barriers
single shot for a shield like for high
level content when you're playing the
stupid shield match game
i don't know how i'm gonna take that one
off because honestly it's so
so many uses and barrier tends to be in
a lot of places i
yeah i've used that one a ton and it's
still even without the particle
deconstruction it's still gonna have
some solid function i'm pretty sure i i
gotta now did you do you have your
catalyst completed yeah it's done
so like you know how's how's that caddy
look how's that what's that doing in
them
i mean
genesis is what the catalyst does
so when you break a shield you get that
right back
so you just basically it keeps your ammo
up more consistently so you break the
shield and then you should have enough
to put some good damage into whatever
you're going to target
with that lily that
absolutely solid of course i mean
particles still a beast i mean typically
like if i'm running with double linears
i'll break it with arbalest like for
barrier and then i'll switch to my heavy
because the heavies do substantially hit
harder um but it's still you know i mean
arbalist is going to be
that the intrinsic barrier and then uh
the genesis perk for a little bit of
ammo i think it's just it's just what it
needed to make it really functional yes
and linears are in a pretty good spot so
yeah that's how i envisioned arbolus to
be when it first dropped remember how we
were kind of underwhelmed oh yeah i
still remember when it was like breaking
shield yeah just it wasn't quite right
so yeah it's definitely better now yes
i'm doing that and then the rest has
been cleaned up i watched your video i
got my um i ran to um banshee and got
that cartesian with the right role
yep doing my dares and um just
to to travis the chagrin i did my
dawning the last day i was i like i went
to all the the last day i was cooking up
with snickerdoodles and all the
foolishness
got all that done got it matched to work
i got my easy bake oven masterwork and
um i i didn't get the what is it the the
the fusion the glacier
i got the reservoir burst but i didn't
get the assistance combo did you get it
in the front
did you get a slide shot maybe or no no
it was like
i got that i got mine on the last day
yeah so i finally got it but i was like
that was like a couple hours before i
was getting ready to go to bed and i
finally was just like kind of relieved
because that's i'd basically been
turning everything in for that because
like the sword i was fine cold front was
okay i got a couple decent avalanches
like i got a system
i got a subsistence adrenaline junkie
like if machine guns get a boost for
like ad clearing purposes that actually
would work fairly well but now the
subsistence glacio classim i wanted and
because i like null composure for the
similar reason me too
i was like it may not be because i
literally used that in my solo build for
grasp of everest so i was like
it would hit harder in granite the
thousands like i'm not entirely sure i'm
gonna love it but i still wanted the
option uh but just the fact that you
could fire and reload and still have
reservoir it's like it's unique that was
the main thing
and that's why i wanted it and i got but
i only think i'm disappointed though the
the the nerf to
heavy aggressive fusions they feel weird
well that's hard yeah the thousand
charge time i hope gets fixed that's
another reason why it's like if they
bring that down some like kind of tweak
that a little better it
it feels like a mi it feels like an hour
to charge that thing up that's why i was
like i got it for now for the possible
future that those high impact ones don't
take six years to charge
yeah but that's been pretty much it and
like i said between halo destiny
demeo
and oh you like this um for for the
holidays i did um
i played overcooked for the first time
and watched me argue with friends about
who didn't cook the burger right who
broke who didn't slice the lettuce
like that gabe yo
you'll break friends yeah you'll you'll
bring friends with that one new year's
had a bunch of the hobies over and we
playing this game and it is absolutely
hilarious
are you talking about uh a sandwich tale
that game no no overcook so basically
like you were in a restaurant yeah
i always thought you were still i
thought you were still talking about the
vr games because those like a vr
sandwich making game that's like really
there's some like vr cooking when i saw
it recently
yeah it's like okay because yeah you
started having the different levels
where you gotta pass stuff back and the
trucks drive apart together and i never
got that far in that one but ariel card
is yeah friendship's getting destroyed
brother
i i was like yo whoo get the pot out get
the burger off the thing
it's so funny and then like you got to
clean the dishes
it's it's hilarious it is
absolutely hell i didn't i start they
told me to start with part one first but
the reason why i want to give it a shout
out is because i gotta get switched
their flowers
we're in the age right now because i
wanted to bring a party game over with
friends and everything is either online
and switch still does local
co-op with four to five people yeah and
it's the best for that i gotta give
switched it like we had so much fun
everybody's got the controller we're all
on one screen and just having a ball so
yeah
i was just saying the first time i ever
saw that game overcooked the way i
became aware of it is i heard screaming
in the ibn office one day and i go over
and there's just people huddled around
the screen and they're all working
together and they were apparently trying
to get three stars on everything
including the end of game ones and i i
walked and i saw them do it and the time
the one time i saw them playing that was
the was the run that they did it and it
was unbelievable i have never seen that
level of coordination it would make
destiny raiders
like disorganized chumps like they were
so on point it was like
this crazy
and there was a whole group of people
around the screen like watching them do
it and everyone was just an odd they
were like how would the how the hell are
they
like working so tightly in tandem
together and i was like i'm going to
play that game that was my expo i was
like i need to play this see i own both
of them they're really good so fun i'm
glad i tried that for the first time so
that was my holiday stuff that i was
doing all the way through
well it is a destiny podcast i guess
we'll talk about that for a minute or
two uh but yeah it's like not to jump
too far off of what we were on
which queen is what's looming we didn't
get a swab today um you know the big
like bomb they dropped on twitter it's
like no twab today but you know it's
just gonna be more like that's a bomb i
know but i was like everybody's like
where's where 12 and they're like no 12
and it was like oh
what
but as witch queen information is gonna
start rolling out in the future weeks
we've got
six weeks basically or so till it starts
really you know till it's in our hands
so the weekly cadence of twabs is
generally going to have a breakdown of
something we've got you know the weapon
crafting campaign probably you know
we'll get a schedule of like raid dates
and stuff like that chat was talking
about that
but as we talked about last time
actually
where do we think it's going to like
rank in you know where do we expect for
it to rank in our years but i travis
actually had a very good idea to say
where would we possibly where do we
think we're going to score this thing
when we get done with it
so to start it off we're gonna let the
ign expert show us how this is done and
then we'll sound off afterwards so
travis
which queen anticipation with everything
that we know right now um kind of break
down you might even break down like how
you kind of come to a score like if
things take away if a raid's really good
it might bump it like
let us understand that we'll kind of
take a piece of it from there
yeah so i think every game is a little
different um in terms of like the the
things that work for it and the things
that don't and kind of like looking at
it critically but the ultimate question
is is the game fun right like is it fun
how fun is it uh like you know what are
the what are the things that aren't that
great and we all know what the things
are in destiny that aren't that great
like the new light experience which i'm
sure we'll be talking about later that's
the next topic stay tuned
yeah next time so uh you know that's
like one area that destiny could always
improve their economy their armor system
uh you know these are the things we
spend all uh
every week talking about um so there's
there's stuff that's bad but um the last
two expansions i reviewed for destiny
have gotten sevens
because
uh mostly because of
content scarcity actually that was like
the main problem with both shadow keep
and beyond light in my opinion was that
you know you you play through the story
in a couple hours you beat the big bad
and then you're sort of running around
and doing the same strikes over again
and lack of new multiplayer maps or
multiplayer modes has been something
that i've railed against on all my
destiny reviews the lack of like a
long-term bad guy or focus for the story
i think i've talked about in every
review i've ever written for destiny and
i've been reviewing destiny not always
for ign but for other outlets my first
review for destiny was the destiny
vanilla which i gave a six
out of ten destiny
one
destiny one destiny one vanilla i gave a
six out of ten i've been reviewing it
for that long um
basically from the beginning and then
the taken king was my first on-site
review where like bungie was like come
out and play the game in bungie
headquarters and like review it like on
site and so yeah i have a long history
of reviewing these these expansions but
um
the last two have been sevens because of
scarcity of content and so for me it'll
be
the one of the big determining factors
will be how much content is actually in
this game and
is is all of it good right um
will the campaign be meaningful and
impact the story in ways that we're not
expecting will
uh it have direction we'll have new
modes or new kind of surprises we're not
expecting how much does it shake up the
sandbox with the new uh glaive weapon
type and armor or weapon crafting rather
well the raid be good the raid uh
definitely helped beyond light yeah
because i wasn't super thrilled by the
campaign but the raid was awesome good
point
like did deep stone crypt like bump at a
point for you or where like before the
raid do you score it before you even get
to the raid or like are you kind of
keeping an ongoing idea in your head or
do you just kind of get the complete
picture and then be like okay where
where did we finally basically i'm sorry
i just saw my uh i just saw my laptop
isn't charging and it's on two percent
battery oh yeah
yeah that'd be that'd be good yeah yeah
uh
i i try not to think about the store the
score for as long as possible to be
honest i try to just like play the game
and immerse myself in everything that it
has to offer and then uh once i get to
the point where i feel like i've played
everything then i start to think about
like well how was my time with this what
were the things that bugged me what were
the things that i liked but you know me
i mean you guys have done a show with me
for half a year you know that i'm like
super annoying like i used to think that
my super power was observation like oh
i'm like sherlock holmes i just noticed
stuff and that's just not true at all as
i'm older i realize my superpower is
that i'm whiny as hell i'm super whiny
and honestly that's that's my superpower
in everything i do like my day job is
because i'm super whiny and i
things bother me that don't bother other
people and i'm able to kind of like get
in there and like fix them and then i'm
a good reviewer i'm a good critic
because i'm also just super whiny yeah
it helps yeah i'm just super whiny it's
very helpful it's like a it's a gift and
a curse because everyone around me hates
me but it's very useful uh
it's very useful in my in my in my life
to kind of have that
uh that crit i'm constantly analyzing
things critically and going well why
isn't it different why and i i do the
same thing with like authority figures
people tell me oh that's the rule and i
go well why is that the rule like it
seems like a challenge just that
annoying little like rebel i was like
yeah uh there's gonna be there's gonna
be comments that would be like man
travis knows himself
oh they already said i do know myself i
am 100
i have a high level of introspection um
when i was in elementary school
i so i if anybody knows me i've
never done drugs and i've never drank
alcohol i'm like straight laced just
because i'm a control freak but um when
i was in elementary school i got
suspended for refusing to take the dare
pledge
wow you guys have to take the dog
they tried to get me to take the dare
pledge and i was in fourth grade and i
was standing up to like this police
officer and going you're brainwashing
people like why should they do this
they don't they don't understand what
this pledge is this is you guys are
fascists and they're like you're
suspended like you're back here what are
you doing
yeah so i just have always been uh in
that way
but yeah
i'm i'm um
i'm going to say
that
that this is going to be a 7 out of 10.
and the reason i'm going to say that is
because i hope to be pleasantly
surprised maybe it'll be an eight or
nine but it could also be worse right it
could be
it could be like a curse of osiris which
in my opinion is like a five out of ten
right so it it could go either way i'm
i'm but i'm just going to be like
the reason a lot of reviews at ign are 7
out of 10 is because most games are good
but not anything special right like it's
very rare that a game is like leaves you
with a bad feeling in your in your mouth
but because most games are just nerf
legends
yeah
obviously
obviously exceptions
um
but yeah uh there there's it's also very
rare that you play a game and it like
blows you away and you're like talking
your friends about it like that's also a
rare occurrence so i think it's safe to
just like
play for the middle right and say it's
probably going to be a good game but not
great
yeah i hope i hope that it's in eight or
nine like in my heart i'm like this has
got to be better than beyond life like
it's got to be better than shadow key
but i i don't know that we have not seen
that from independent bungie yet so i'm
just i'm waiting for them to have that
breakout game that makes me go okay they
can create a forsaken or a taken king
uh with the current team without the
backing of activision like i'm waiting
for that to happen
sure yeah that's fair except man
yeah i'm like
i'll be whereas what is it uh he says
he's the travis is the king of whiney i
guess i'm the king of optimism right i'm
mr positive you know it's all right or
whatever
it'll be okay
yeah what it is i think the reason why
i'm leading that way is because
i feel like they are internally in a
place
of confidence that remember a couple
months back
you know they were just screaming from
the rooftops it punches yeah and i'm
just like hmm
so y'all seeing something internally
that clearly you are excited about now
again that could be just more future
stuff right it doesn't necessarily have
to be all pertaining to which queen but
the track record is generally good i
think
they they they always remember i've said
this before eb you know going to
flashback days like they always remind
me of that kid who dilly dally's during
school but then like you know midterms
and
but like that final exam they generally
tend to show up they cram to the very
last minute and then they show up and
you're like oh okay just when you're
about to lose faith in them that's when
they were like getting 65s or b minor
you know c minuses or whatever the hell
really passed that last quiz yeah like
they've been barely passing we always go
i don't know bungie like y'all messing
up bro forgot to turn their homework on
season of the worthy you know yeah it's
like activision y'all still messing up
you know what i mean you know the school
tropes it's it's like and then they the
big thing happens
and it's just like okay now to travis's
point though
this is a new day this is still
bungee on your own right so we got to
see them execute that on their own and
you know to travis's point like beyond
light in my opinion
it was okay
but the raid bumped it up for me
personally if deep stone [ __ ] wasn't as
good as deep stone [ __ ] was i don't know
if i'm giving them a high super high
score we had you know it's a new
subclass yeah but it was kind of busted
coming in that we all knew i mean the
story did not i was gonna say in
fairness like
for travis giving it a seven as sunset
had just gone into session at that point
like and there was like lack of loot and
stuff like when i sat there and think
about a seven i was like
you were probably almost on the generous
relatively generous side like seven was
probably yeah and as i said i was like
that raid probably gave it just an edge
to not make it a six i'm thinking
yeah for me the raid you know that's
funny
oh sorry sorry i don't mean no no no no
no no no no no i was gonna say is what
what's funny is uh destin always used to
get flamed for writing destiny reviews
for ign because he did the reviews
before i started doing them right um but
i've never gotten pushback on my destiny
reviews because i
i put out sevens and the fans are like
yeah i mean i'm not gonna say it's an
eight and then the people who don't like
destiny point to it and go oh yeah seven
that means that the game sucks you know
right because they're just looking for
ways to hate but i always end up like
right in the middle i always want to be
the guy who writes the extreme review or
everybody's like ah but no matter what i
do even if i give you a play you get
done
metacritic
i look at metacritic and it's got a one
and a three and i'm like right in the
middle i'm like damn how does this keep
happening
you yeah give like destiny the final
shape a 10 and then you'll just you know
freak everybody out
then people will hate me yeah i've never
given a 10. never in my life i don't
know if you could give something a 10
just due to your nature is that your
nature i can't see i was like yeah
okay what would you give halo infinite
see i actually had this debate on a uh
we did a halo round table and i said
which i watched if i was reviewing it
i think i would have a difficult time
not giving it a 10. because a 10 for ign
does not mean perfect it means
masterpiece right
if you read the description of the of
the review it says we hope that games in
the future will like learn from this
game and like model things off of it
when i think about it i'm like god i
hope like shooters learn from halo
infinite and realize like that's how to
do the multiplayer sandbox and that's
how to do like uh a campaign like i
would have a hard time doing i actually
do have a lot of problems with halo
infinite mostly around like story and
they're kind of like shifting uh uh i
don't want to compare it to this but
they did a very similar like rise of
skywalker thing where they chose one
direction and some fans didn't like it
and then they tried to turn and retcon a
bunch of stuff and uh i probably act
like five didn't exist
yeah kind of well they don't they they
embrace it but they they do what what
rise of skywalker did which is they say
yeah that exists but it doesn't matter
matter right like it's sort of yeah um
which i i think is kind of like the move
when there's fan backlish i personally
think that developers and writers of
story should never listen to the fans
because they have no idea what they're
talking about um and and that's just my
opinion i think they
people listen to fans are just always
screwing things up uh but anyway um halo
infinite i probably would have given a
masterpiece it's possibly possible that
the reason i've never given a 10 is
because people don't let me review games
that are that good
see that's holding you back see and
that's the interesting thing of like
anybody who gives anybody a score
because i listen to skillup tassie you
ryan mccaffrey
like i've heard you guys all talk about
it in different ways and you know
everybody has their different pieces of
what
you know grains on you more for example
maddie absolutely hated death loop
i mean like with an absolutely i saw
that with a pet with no smaller passions
and it's like and i think i think that's
i was actually talking to cog about this
one i think it was like for
like and i'm not saying his thoughts are
unjustified because i think for him
he is like die hard arcane seemed like
he like loved
dishonored one even more on dishonored
two he's like he could see where they're
going
and then i spent like and then
to him it didn't deliver but then as you
said like to the masses
it's a different and that was for me it
was my first arcane game
and like i'm not saying i wouldn't enjoy
the other ones but it was just the first
one i played and i had fun in the
sandbox because it was the first one for
me it was kind of goofy um yeah skill up
also just like death loop so it's like
yeah but i have to say i have to say
there's a difference between a game
being your biggest personal
disappointment which is what it sounds
like it was to matty it sounds like it
was his personal biggest disappoint his
his expectations were here and it
delivered
down here for him it's different between
that and being the worst game of the
year right because he wanted a 12. he
got like a seven but to him it was a two
yeah
right and that's exactly yeah
but to say that that's the worst game of
the year just tells me you did not play
a lot of games that came out this year
because there were some really bad games
this year man like
i i it just it blows my mind definitely
is a great game listen
i will give the man this he is on his
square he takes all the criticism he
fights the boy he goes in and i get it
and he has justifications for why he
doesn't like it yeah yeah he's not like
he's just saying it's uh yeah it's like
he's dark connoisseur and listen i i
disagree but you know i i respect his
opinion i understand the perspective of
where he's coming from as the arcane guy
but i'm with e
i know it's the type of game i'm gonna
like i know the fact that the masses
like it for that reason he just knows in
his mind it's the the dumbed-down
version of his favorite studio genre
whatever but anyway back to what i was
saying um
you know with witch queen it's just like
yeah we you know beyond finishing up the
beyond light part was was the deep stone
[ __ ] and how that really elevated things
for me and that really and i if you i'm
a little biased i'm definitely biased if
you deliver me a great raid if you give
me a great raid that really resonates
with me and which queen has a lot of
pressure because it's twofold it's one
resolution
on a
taken king campaign level that i want to
see not that it has to be we beat her or
anything like that but
it just has to respect this character
and all the build up of years and hype
and lore and you know how we feel if
it's like
yeah yeah and we killed it
like if it's a high yah moment and it's
over
uh you know what i'm saying it they got
to be very careful now i i'm confident
in the fact that
over this past year
we got to put our heads together for the
narrative team y'all come on yeah and
now
for for 2021
the narrative team has been in their bag
so i am confident that they will at
least respect what's going on how this
you know how we get there and then what
we do next but i do want to see how this
rate is that's going to be big for me
and then to your point e the the the the
day-to-day mechanics the the what
crafting really does is that
is it a gimmick
dude are you really crafting destiny
like you didn't say like what are you
doing right so then you know we got a
shout out he said that thing those
moments facts facts dj you know so it's
like what are you really doing
and then we know there's to be a sandbox
update right we know it we know they got
some stuff boy that's pretty good i know
it's not small
right
we got to see
really cool execution we
i'm going to use the outriders example
outriders did some things y'all
it really did some things as far as
quality of life in this in the lunar
shooter sandbox i'm curious
and with the generally with destiny my
last point i'll say is this generally
with destiny when it comes to expansions
they they tend to do
good as far as changing
gameplay and tropes and problems and
really getting into the mechanics of
making the game better right
i want to see what they have in mind
because that's the pressure to me
trav me like there's certain things
we're like come on destiny we talk about
crucible at nauseam we talk about gambit
and nauseum there are fundamental things
that are still
broken but not in a good state
they've got to really complete i would
say right so that this kind of
i i don't think they're going to address
any of the creativity yeah that's kind
of where i'm playing i think that's way
down the road i think i know it's
yeah and if that's the case then i'm
back with travis on it's going to be a
7-ish kind of kind of kind of an
expansion there if that's if that's
going to feel like
all the destiny expansions have been
dodging the 6 from me
right like beyond light was like headed
towards six and then the raid like
knocked it it was like all right cool we
got it and i don't really remember a lot
about my review shadow keep but i
remember it was like on the cusp and
then i was like all right it's gonna be
a seven like it's gonna get there but i
i would like to see it do the opposite
we're dodging the seven for like an
eight or nine yeah yeah
yeah yeah climb up there um because it's
just been a little there's always been
something missing like beyond light it
was like the campaign and then making
this in the sandbox they took that's
what i forgot
i disliked the end of beyond lights
campaign
i didn't like the fake out with the
freezing of of old girl the fallen you
know what i mean to me i always felt um
clovis bray should have been and was the
better character to build around that's
just me no i i felt the lament question
was way better yeah no i was literally
gonna say exactly like the clovis bray
stuff is what actually added
depth
and like some character building and
getting to see the history between elsie
and anna like
seeing that type of stuff
yeah like i got a lot more out of that
post campaign yeah i feel like i got out
of like the lieutenants and stuff now
granted i will say aramis had
more than you know
the veil previously before and you know
destiny 2's
red war campaign actually still wasn't
bad but aaron
of herself wasn't bad because even in
the previews we got a little bit of
empathy at least a little bit we
understood a little more but it was like
the clovis near miss and um or clovis
anna elsie that trio and then you saw
lament and banshee like yeah the whole
thing old things so good and and that's
why the raid resonated with me because
even though i didn't like tannic's remix
but i like clovis throughout i like
clovis talkity you damn invaders his
status calamitous yeah he's talking to
you like there's moments you know
even when you do the what is it the the
skywalk what like
the way he talks to you with that that
that genius level of arrogance
like how dare you invade my spirit how
dare you you know you know what you're
doing do you know who i am why i did
like he was the guy i was hoping we'd
get some type of ai simulation against
him but i digress i'll give it to you
you know what else bothered me about the
story let's go if we can talk about this
let's get it let's get it let's get it
let's get it the whole plot line of the
darkness it felt like was really not
well handled like
they they invite the stranger out and
the stranger says some crazy stuff the
stranger's like yo there's a whole bunch
of other realities i'm from one of them
and in that reality guardian started
using the darkness and became evil and
it destroyed everything and you're like
whoa whoa whoa okay go back
there's a multiverse or there's at least
different timelines you're from one of
them and you came here
and your first thought was hey you guys
should use the darkness here
what like
so many questions zavala's little lineup
you're not gonna use that right wink
wink yeah but then the stranger's like
the stranger's like yo i'm from a world
where like this backfired in a big way
we all became evil and killed everybody
anyway i'm gonna help you use the
darkness and then
and then they don't really like you
don't get really any closer
understanding what the darkness is
just sort of using it and then the story
doesn't even focus on that the story
focuses on this other thing that's
happening with the fallen that feels
totally disconnected and i was like can
we get back to the multiple realities
thing like that seems like a way bigger
problem like why are we not talking
about that like why do that's kind of in
the story
yeah
that's kind of been the story of destiny
forever is that there's always been a
way bigger problem and we never address
it i'm like oh well we gotta stop we
gotta stop this other thing that's
happening it's like what like well that
was what are we doing well that was the
end of season of arrivals too when all
of the ships came in we lost like four
planets and then we haven't talked about
it for like a year
destiny reminds me sometimes of someone
use example like in the mcu you know
like when loki came to fight the
avengers but we all know thanos is about
like they have a bunch of loki's running
around and we just fight loki all that
we fight the mid boss the sub boss all
the time and the main character boss
eludes us it never gets
and then they forget yeah the video so
that's actually one of the things about
this one is sabathun has been one of
those
far-reaching kind of gods because i mean
taking king was five years ago now
um
at that level we haven't experienced
like you know crota to taking king and
the expansion and like regicide and
going through all that like we're
finally at one of those kind of levels
kind of again we do feel like there's
more beyond saboteur whether it's the
veil whether darkness not entirely sure
of course
but it is one of those to where
sabathune again as we've said
has more weight and has more gravitas to
her than we've had in a long time like
aramis is like it's a fallen captain
okay
we know yeah cool you know you're
getting defeated easily
that's that's fine like sabathune on the
other hand
if that goes down the same way we're
gonna have a problem if you know
sabathune ends up back in her little
chrysalis it's like that's
yeah yeah um so you digging no i was
gonna say well so what where'd you end
up on score about seven as well or
seven until he's being optimistic he
wants an eight i want to i want he wants
a nine you know what
i'll put it out i'm gonna go i'm gonna
shoot for the stars eight
i'll shoot for the stars that's the
stars
those stars are still within reach man
you got to set those a little farther
away only because they're themselves
what if it's the best thing by far and
like it blows us all away it's like
masterpiece level i don't it's kind of
crazy it could do enough none of us
think it's going to be that if that's
crazy trap if it ain't got home which we
put on that many to put no 10 on it you
know that man don't even play okay so
they're literally chat saying some of
the stuff i've been thinking about you
guys have said some of it as well and
it's all kind of valid but there's like
as we played through multiple of these
what makes things great when the
campaign ties into the raid
just like in taken king and regicide
forsaken to last wish
you know witch queens campaign into the
name of that raid if those link together
in some way that's already a step up
because that narrative cohesion is
something we've asked for and really
enjoyed when it does happen sparsely but
we've really enjoyed when it does
so it's like is there going to be a
narrative cohesion between the campaign
and the raid we know it's in some
pyramid ship is it going to be like oh
by the way can you go take care of the
pyramid ship over in the throne world
that thing's annoying or is it like
this is some weird shattered piece of my
mind i don't know it's like is it gonna
be cool or is it gonna not and there's
there's little things as well you said
armor 3.0 i have low expectations there
that's fine i don't have my hopes up we
got artifice armor if that's where
things start to go just you know maybe
more of a half step or zero energy slots
or something but again like things that
have been stagnant for a while outside
of crucible which we've obviously talked
about we know the cadence of crucible
unfortunately
now we don't know when all the modes are
coming they said they have worked on
other modes there's like two modes plus
rift
i don't know the cadence that those are
going to be released maybe we do get a
new remote conversation that's coming
rift is coming they've said rift is
coming to 22
plus two other modes that they're
working on
oh wow okay so those but but again if
those don't come with beyond with uh
which queen
then travis is gonna be like i have to
review what i have in front of me which
is completely fair
and that's the that's kind of the thing
of a year of destiny versus the
expansion review because i can't when
he's like hey lack of content we haven't
got dust we haven't got crucial maps
gambit's dying off in the desert
somewhere
it's like the weapons were very light so
the fact that we had the campaign the
osiris stuff was kind of cool stasis did
mix things up in the raid seven makes
sense but it's like for me
artifact
is getting very it's very stagnant i did
a video on this like long ago and it
hasn't really changed
so like that would be nice to see a
rework and we've asked about like what's
the leveling system going to be like
i know not all of the big things are
going to be fixed in one expansion they
tend to you know do a big chunk per
season or whatever it's going to be
but again it's like is the artifact
going to get a refresh after two years
are the champions which are what they
lean so heavily on in any high level
content are the champions finally gonna
get
either at least a recoding a little bit
of rework some changes a little more
flexibility in the mods like or is it
still gonna be this here's your three
weapons that you can use for the
champions this is your meta for three
months are we still going to be in that
department um i feel like the champions
have to be the uh
the hive guardians right
yeah i mean perfect for it right
it feels like that could be a cool thing
again how do they implement it i don't
know but hopefully
um so i mean artifact is one just
because that we do interact with that so
much each season it leads into what each
season's loadouts tend to be
uh champions we interact with them at
high level content all the time
um crafting a lot of my weight is going
to be what crafting does
because that's going to be the systems
again like what's umbrals have been kind
of this thing well the prismatic
recaster and the umbral decoder are
bye-bye
i don't know what they're going to be
redoing if that's just going straight
into crafting and if that's the case we
need to see how they do it is it well
done
when outriders was like hey here's
transmog completely fee for everything
or is it bungie's version of transmog
which version of crafting are we going
to get and that's the question is i
don't know i don't think it's going to
be as bad as the five economy transmog
we got but i also don't think it's gonna
be here's the cool version that you all
wish to hope for it's gonna be that
weird time-gated
stretched-out thing that like might be
in between that bungie's probably gonna
do for
multiple reasons it's like
i would love to say that this thing
could be a nine in my eyes
i would love to say that and i was like
and if they can deliver on some of the
things that i'm hoping for i'm not
they've they've talked about crucible
they're building that team
weapons seem to be coming more
frequently
i can see some of the steps if the story
is a banger if it has connection to the
raid if there's any cool secrets that
we've got we've got it like if there are
enough of the things there for me it
could be a destiny 9 which is a weird
way to say that
um
but it's like destiny 9.
that's hilarious
i know i know what he's saying
in the ecosystem of destiny this is like
very high content but if he were grading
it it would still be like a seven yeah
if you were just like yeah for public
consumption and that's that's kind of
enforceability like is in chat he's like
no shot bungie gets weapon correct and
that's the thing is like i don't have
the faith unfortunately that a system is
going to be just nailed and nothing
against bungie because i feel like
they're very capable
i feel like as we've talked about before
that it's going to be that's like a
pittsburgh
tank stupid um
but i think it's one of those things
where
we ask why is transmog the way it is
and it's when the people who are not
making the game it's when the finances
make some decisions
when those get in the way when it's the
engagement metrics that they're making
sure are higher for extended p when
those types of things get in the way of
what the gameplay model we would all
like to see that's when it you know
starts knocking it down a peg okay uh
i'm going to say
i'm going to say eight
oh see you right there with me no butter
i was like
the ign style of eight but it's like but
again if they did like hey we reworked
and then like if the next six weeks
of twabs are like hey we're reworking
the artifact doing this stuff hey you
got a couple new champions coming in
plus those hive guardians you don't even
know about void 3.0 is just like baller
uh weapon crafting nailed it that's when
that thing can start climbing up to like
nines for me like a legitimate knight
but it's like there are a lot of systems
that i don't know about and previous
experience doesn't have enough faith for
me to rank it higher until i know more
so what
no go ahead
no i was gonna just quick question uh
what
would hold more weight to you
narrative
story impact
but
gameplay changes are not all the way to
your liking or
let's say magically
they really address core gameplay core
armor corp you know they really and then
the story is okay
which one holds more weight to you
because the vibe i get from you it's
it's really more of the systems the the
the the builds the armor and that aspect
of the loop that if this is not that you
don't value story
no that let me um
i love how people are now putting
different locations yeah and different
ratings we've got a canadian four we've
got a carolina 5.5
shout out
it's it's dj's
i think canadians are too polite yeah
they're too nice it's got to be like
it's a 6.9 they can't be too low
if this was final shape i would say the
story has to be amazing it has to be a
banger to end it out as sabothune is not
the end of this thing
and i know we've got season 17 season 18
season 19 continuing the storytelling i
sort of storytelling is almost better in
the seasons
yes so
if the seasons keep the storytelling
telling going well but the mechanics are
solid our year would be more enjoyable
in the longer run
so
if i want to log into destiny and have a
really cool experience for witch queen
but then the mechanics suck for the rest
of the year or do i have an okay
experience in the story and it's kind of
an errors thing but they like revamped
the game
that's going to make my year more
enjoyable so i would lean to the more
enjoyable year with a questionable story
i would love to have both
but if i have to pick yeah texas
two-step yeah there you go yes there you
go
because we do play this game all damn
year long the seasonal stories have been
really good and if that's where they
focus the stories and the mechanics are
still solid then that's a more enjoyable
year even though it may come out as like
a seven or even a six but if the year is
good then that's a better you know it's
like new light experience gets reworked
like you know you come in that's a lot
like there are a lot of things that
could be better for the year
which would make the whole year better
so fair fair enough i respect it
a lot of pressure on them we go see they
deliver but they're like i said they'd
be yelling budget
yeah
that's that's kind of the thing
and that's the thing is what is the
cadence of what they've seen
is it coming with witch queen is it like
because we know we're getting void 3.0
arc 3.0 solar 3.0 during the course of
the year we're starting with void
but what else do we not know
and that's the biggest questions is is
crafting cool like is crafting cool is
the campaign replay have they what have
they kept from us
right yeah are there gonna be any
surprises good point good point
what they also um the lucid brood i
wanna see the mechanics you know
confirming we have to kill the ghost to
kill them after we put them down right
because we've seen that the cinema of
them
our guardian smashing a ghost after
killing the league is that just like a
finishing move or how's that right the
story with that the the
weather what the hell happens you know
widow cyrus what what the hell happens
with crow character development on all
these other npcs that we got to know
what's going on do we get some
curveballs do we get some deaths you
know do we get what's going on with with
my man um you know mr gambit himself
like yeah he's supposed to play a major
role you know this kind of thing yeah
yeah he still isn't explaining now i
know they can't get every thread in
every loop but what i want is what kind
of travis alluded to last last word
which we were talking about
battlegrounds and we were talking about
one thing we liked about it was the
involvement of every npc on some level
where it felt like a living world i
don't like these in the corner
completely self-contained stories that
involve only two to three npcs and
that's it i want the world affected i
want everybody involved on some level
and you start to see the narrative team
kind of take shape that last year
because you started to get more players
you start to see
and i like that they keep that momentum
going i i want that on the i'm going to
be hard on them on the story if the
story does not deliver
they can't ooga [ __ ] thank you
can not
if long time listeners will understand
this but
uh cog and i have a mutual disdain for
this tactic that bungie employs where
they claim that something's going to be
like this
insidious like oh sabathune's going to
like work her way and she's got a master
plan and all that stuff and then when it
comes time to pay the piper uh all of a
sudden the monster just pops up and goes
and then you kill it and then that's the
end of the encounter and you're like
okay so it wasn't really worth all that
it's almost like sam in the hallway of i
just got done watching the lord of the
rings so it's like sam in the last one
when he's trying to free frodo from the
orcs towards the end when he's the
shadows like screaming he's walking up
the stairs and they're like oh and then
he pops out and it's like it's a hobbit
what are you doing to me like
yeah
that oryx is the only one of the few
who's done that oryx is one of the few
ones who's gone regicide was cool
but you're not done with me i'm massive
like when he was in and that's that's
kind of that's about the only one i can
remember and i think that's why that is
so highly
renowned forsaken last wish is probably
the other style so again it's like this
every other so again if savithoon
can have one of those kind of moments
some big last wish ahamkara or oryx in
his throne world
whatever is in this pyramid ship or
story something along those levels as
you said not the oogabooga here's the
following here's the fallen captain
the remnants of
the the completion like remember we had
taken war moments things still going on
we had
yo forsaken okay now we've unlocked the
dreaming city oh my god what is this
right like like that's why what travis
is saying is so key like what else are
they holding on to because you need
also those moments to bring the wonder
and joy because if it's just
uh
we are going to be disgusted people are
going to be like you made me wait all
these years to do that
and like i said the uber booger and
don't hire savithum don't come in there
and we we we z zol
remembers
[Music]
that was like a seasonal level so it's
like but again
we just killed a worm god and i'm like
really
scale wasn't bad just shot him in the
face a few times and he's done in a
strike and you're like oh this fight
murdered him got him out of there like
come on
i think they've learned i i i i i'm
hoping i do yeah i i think we we we're
past that ooga booga stage those old
days and hopefully the better days
i agree that we're that they've learned
but i don't know that their capacity has
changed good points you provide the
types of experiences that people want in
fact it's gotten harder on them they're
working with a smaller team smaller
budget and i feel like sometimes their
eyes are bigger than their stomach yes
creatively speaking or they'll build up
this thing and then when it's time to
actually deliver they can you know they
strip down ideas and things get taken
out of the game or they get pushed into
a different thing and
um who knows
if they're going to actually be able to
do everything that they envisioned for
this expansion especially with the delay
and with the fact that you know they're
working through cohort and all this
other stuff i just i'm really really
worried that this expansion is going to
come out and it's going to feel like
it's way too small for how long we
waited and how long it's meant to
sustain us
that's what the pressure is especially
after the delay right yeah it's a lot of
they and and and the only thing i will
defend them is
we are a ravenous base
we eat this i mean
yeah we're gonna burn through it so fast
that is the that is the least of my
worries because i get annoyed that
destiny fans are like oh i want to be
able to play the game every hour of
everything
because i'm like i don't i want to play
i kind of do please don't make that much
content destiny
yeah you you you're that type like you
want them to have so much content
because you're this is like your bread
butter right well he's actually going to
be able to
oh really yeah he likes to live in it
but he i mean yeah it's like i'll let
you speak for you let me know
more than most i mean yeah it's like my
youtube channel i cover it so i'm biased
if they give us new stuff here and that
type of stuff but i also do
i'm at the point where it's like
i can get creative and come up with
things for videos to a point which you
know everybody you can see how stretched
people are depending on if you have
vault cleaning videos that are coming
out lately which is fine i mean believe
me it's actually entertaining when you
go look at my vault it's probably tragic
but
yeah it's like there's a point to where
having i mean we've been talking about
the seasons it's like you're going to
make me log in for eight weeks don't
mean
make me wait to week 14 six weeks later
to get the rest of the story so it's
like yeah it's like i'm with yeah
there's gonna be a conglomerate of like
you know six to eight weeks where it's
gonna be a decent amount of stuff going
on
i am okay with the lulls because
at some point i've got to play these
other amazing games that i want to play
right so much i i also so much i also
don't want to have
i don't want to have to play so much
destiny that i end up hating it because
i've had periods in my life where like
you know i i think probably
especially destiny won vanilla after
vaulted blast came out and i was playing
it and i was a forever 29 i was lying on
every week and i was running around this
patrol areas collecting spin map
i was at a point i was like i don't know
why i'm doing this like i hate that i'm
playing this game so much and and i i
would much prefer it if i could log on
and have this amazing experience and
then log off and and log back on once
they've got something new for me to
experience i'm okay with the weekly
login as long as it's not i have to log
in for a week and play like that entire
week to keep up you know what i mean i
want to be able to play like a couple
hours here and there and
so
from my perspective if i'm critic if i'm
being a critic of destiny
um
i don't think
uh lack of a long grind is going to be
the thing that keeps me back what's
going to keep me back is if the game
feels like it's really bare bones and
you play for a couple hours in the
campaign and then you're sort of going
back to doing the same strikes you were
doing before that is hard to yeah that's
hard to stomach that and what
i'll add on one quick thing i'll give it
to you what will disgust me
is if
what's the expression that the juice is
not worth the squeeze yes
when you bother me if we do all this and
these wars ain't great and the grind is
very unforgiving and it's just not a
payoff which i think they've learned
from they've been great with the i feel
with the weapons lately and
and for the most part managing that but
they also have to like we talked about
they have to fill in these gaps with
more interesting weapons more new stuff
you know half working that fine line of
not balancing just to reta the retreads
and bringing retreads back all the time
but i mean
i know tassie's been big on this in
defending them and i do agree with it if
you look at it objectively there is more
new stuff than there is old stuff but
that's always going to be what the
perception is right like the perception
is like oh you just reaction whatever
whatever they still have to get on it
with the new stuff and make sure that
it's interesting and the content is
worthwhile that's the pressure that
they're always going to be under it's
just the the
it's being a developer for this game
called destiny that you always underlie
that but again he was about to say so no
i mean that was kind of where i was
going but
like with regards to what comes with
also i was gonna ask you guys your
thoughts on
and i was going to ask kind of travis
this
we don't know the name of season 16.
we're in 15 right now
i think
yeah
do you take any of the seasonal content
into play when it comes to
your discussion because those are
technically now separate purchases if
you didn't do
it i was like we'll probably get some
free activity that's probably going to
be the seasonal activity they seem to
have that cadence does that play does
the free stuff play in is like a new
activity for you
where does that fall and also
as this is the season that launches with
an expansion
where do you guys think this season's
gonna rank in the plethora of seasons
we've had previously
yeah um so the the answer to that is
that
when i am evaluating the expansion i
mean i'm evaluating just the stuff that
you get in that expansion but that said
it's sort of impossible to completely
disconnect that from stuff that you get
from the season because the season also
adds weapons and kind of overall impacts
the sandbox and stuff like that so
void 3.0 everybody's going to get
presumably and so that's you know kind
of not part of it but it is so my
question is is the content of the
expansion good
and i don't really focus on any of the
stuff in the season for two reasons one
because it's technically not part of the
package that i'm reviewing uh even
though it does definitely influence it
but the second reason is that if i was
reviewing the entire season
i would have to write my review over the
course of like four months
because
uh the seasons take forever to complete
and you don't really get to see the end
until the end and by the time i i would
finish my review
uh nobody would be able to benefit from
my review like oh hey uh i'm gonna i'm
gonna write us a review of season of the
lost uh on february 20th okay well
nobody's gonna be able to play it at
that point so who's the review for i
mean i have to write the review as
quickly as possible so that it can
actually help people make decisions
about how to spend their time and their
money um and so yeah there's a few
reasons reviewing seasonal games is
really tricky and i don't even think the
review model is particularly it's almost
like a post it's doing it uh what's the
word i'm looking for
postmortem yeah postmortem that's that's
a better way you would do is like how
what is it like you know a post-mortem
on seasonal loss like how did it end up
once you have all the information
mm-hmm that almost seems more fitting
for a seasonal complete
yeah that's a completely uh valid thing
and i think that i i really like
watching videos that do that as a
destiny fan but as a review that is not
the purpose of making sense the purpose
of the review is to say you know is this
worth your time is it worth your money
and and here's what we think of it at a
critical level so that you can make a
decision and that's really hard to do
for a live service game but i think it
is important for games like destiny that
still charge you for these major
expansions because to be honest
if destiny just did season passes and
didn't have these big annual releases
that they charged you for
igem probably wouldn't review them
we might review them if they had large
uh expansions um that were free because
we don't really care about the price
because we can still say is this game
worth your time like that's a completely
valid reason to do review but we don't
we're not reviewing season the lost for
example
and the reason we're not reviewing
season the loss is because it's sort of
one of those things that's hard to
review the people who are playing it are
already destiny try you know lovers that
are probably not looking for reviews
anyway right and it doesn't have a large
cost associated with it either so it's
kind of just not really good content
review it's like reviewing a season of
fortnight like we don't do that yeah
exactly who would that review before
right like it doesn't really make sense
um but yeah
it is uh it's very difficult to walk
that line when you're doing a review of
a live service game and i don't think
the review model is actually really well
equipped for five service games to be
honest
but
um you know i know enough about destiny
where i feel completely confident
writing a review of it if it wasn't me
doing it if i saw some dude
reviewing destiny who hasn't played
since destiny 2 vanilla i'd be like bro
do not touch yourself
people are going to be people are going
to be telling you oh that wasn't even
part of this or oh you missed this part
of the story this one over your head and
i yeah i would i would hate to be
reviewing this sort of game if i didn't
keep up with it as much as i do you kind
of have like it is one of those that you
do kind of have to be
with within most of the time i mean you
can look at
a lot of different pieces you can try to
gather information but if you haven't
you know lived through the moments and
kind of been in the zeitgeist of destiny
it's hard to really have a feel on where
you know a new expansion sits and like
black run was saying seasons need
reviews maybe within the first week
because like the most you could do when
a season comes quick is like
how do these activities compare to the
previous activities that like
is sundial a fun activity is it
rewarding is it worth your time is the
system of upgrading the seasonal
you know
vendor npc menu page like is that going
to be frustrating or is it time gated in
your face like that type of stuff
imagine trying to review it that first
week too e because if we did that on
festival the loss we wouldn't know about
the three week rotation on the first
week be it in that the shattered exactly
right
we wouldn't know where the story was
heading really we we haven't had our
long conversations yeah that's why
we're really cool yeah it's hard yeah
like all that stuff it's like you don't
have any of the content
some of them we probably could have
reviewed that first week like sundial in
my opinion that we could have just
written that review the first week if we
but we didn't know that until later that
that was really all that the that it had
um so i i just think it's really hard to
do these sorts of things
you got to pick your battles and choose
which ones to review i will say this
though
i wish there were people reviewing the
destiny expansions who had no
involvement in the game prior because i
feel like that's a
really valid viewpoint for that type of
player imagine you're not a destiny
player right and you want to know if
it's time to jump in with a good chance
this expansion my review might not help
you yeah my review will be from a guy
who has nothing in common with you right
like i i play destiny every week and my
review is going to be from that
perspective and i think there is value
in somebody who does not play absolutely
for that player um i was like and that
ties honestly there's some porsche out
there reviewing no and that ties in
perfectly because
you've got players right now like you
pretty much you know t-balled that segue
pretty well yeah so way to go
um new lights that is a thing it's like
it's
what is the experience when somebody's
like hey i haven't played destiny in a
while i remember hearing about this
sabbath chick somewhere in the lore who
knows where
let me and i can buy this deluxe you
know i got friends who are still playing
let me jump back in now
but again like what yeah what would the
experience be like if hadn't played
destiny 2 played some destiny 1 had some
fun had some friends that have been
getting into it they're dragging you
along dragging you along they're like
hey get the deluxe edition we're in this
thing for the next year and you just log
in with the deluxe edition and go
what is that experience like because
again they're still missing some of the
old expansions they don't have some of
that stuff in there they're missing the
forsaken story you can go read about it
on a timeline or you or a byte video
that would be a really interesting
review
to do like the fresh purchase jump in
and like go hard and level but now you
gotta level all the way up to try and
get to end game which who knows what the
base level is probably gonna be 1300 or
something's gonna be they'll bump it all
up
um but yeah like new lights especially
have a really weird time right now in
the game
um
they literally have been held hostage
and dares of eternity and i didn't even
think about this when it started
but even worse when 30th anniversary
launched and i didn't under know
what quite was happening until like i
saw one or two things fall down on
twitter and then it became this like
thing that's kind of exploded so when
there's 30th anniversary launched we all
booted in but we've been playing the
game for a while so we're like okay cool
and here's the new activity play you
know their horse and all the crazy stuff
happens you go through it's like oh that
was kind of fun and you see those are a
little prize at the end you're like all
right so this is the zero activity that
we saw the pictures for
a brand new player right now who is 1100
power level
logs in goes straight into dares of
eternity that is 11.50
50 power levels when you probably have
blue squad you don't even go to
cosmodrome first
you load into this first thing is power
like season level one
and they are screwed basically you can't
get through it until you beat it right
yeah you can't get through until you
finish it and then for some reason it's
been like groups of six of these new
lights
because it like matched all their light
levels together for some reason they all
got lumped in together so you have six
people who are 50 power levels under
with garbage equipment in the first
place trying to do this activity and
they don't even know what is going on
so
what happened on twitter recently
i was gonna say i'll just explain like
what's gonna say yeah go ahead uh just
what happened on twitter the word
started to get out for some of like the
people who like you know are really deep
into this community they were thrown on
like masquerade mass to drop their power
level pulling stuff out of the vault and
going in as low power level as possible
to match up with these people and you'd
see a level season level 526 and a
season level one in the same dares of
eternity and these people are trying to
drag these level ones through this
activity just so they can get into the
destiny like just so they can get into
destiny
that is what happened with theirs of
eternity and that's been going on since
theirs launched
yeah
that is unbelievable
unbelievable and it just it it
reinforces this idea this theory i've
had for a long time the destiny the
bungie does not think at all about new
light players like they spend like so
little brain capacity on thinking about
new players that it's like not even
something and it makes sense right like
if i worked at bungie you're around all
these people that are working on the
game and playing on the game and all
that stuff like the last thing on your
mind are new players and i feel like the
one group that was ever thinking about
new players was activision because
they're concerned about the bottom line
how are we going to grow this game and
how are we going to bring in new players
and so they were probably the only devil
on their shoulder going hey you should
be thinking about how we can grow the
player base and that sort of stuff i
just think it's it's crazy that this
even happened it's crazy that
no one like this this went through
hundreds of people who helped make
destiny and not one of them was like yo
this is gonna be a huge problem imagine
if you log in and you haven't played the
game before like it's that just doesn't
make any sense and what i was gonna say
e when you were describing the problem
even if it didn't match people with the
same light level even if there was like
two guys and then four people that just
carried them through yeah i wouldn't
want to play destiny anymore if my first
10 minutes with the game where me just
getting destroyed
for like 10 full minutes so prime
example of that actually happened to me
because right now it's really funny
because you lower your light level i was
like 10 78 i like dropped it hard with
the mask it's zero so it's pretty easy
to get down that low
right uh i went into one and everybody
did the same thing you'd like loaded and
you're seeing power level like weird
power levels not 1100 exactly like weird
and then you see somebody the vex i'm
like okay well of course you played for
a little bit so like so then i got out
and loaded in again and i saw one who
was level like you know dead on 1100
season rank 1 i was like perfect we go
in
we did not even try and do the first
jump he somehow got to the menu
left
so exactly what you said he's like well
i'm dying in here what now grated if you
quit you will actually go to the menu so
that's what you technically aren't able
to do but i also saw a picture on
twitter where the thing had been lasting
for an hour and five minutes
there's a dares timer on twitter like i
saw a picture an hour and five minutes
long that some people were in dares
i guess who were persistent and trying
to get through this thing or they just
don't know yeah they don't know
destiny like taking out the ghosts and
holding why you might just not know that
mechanic yet yeah absolutely yeah
there's this
i i just struggle with
the
algorithm like how did this get passed
like like how did
making a mandatory
activity at the launch of the game
get
past power level
yeah mistakes are mistakes but it's like
that is egregious like i just don't
understand it like what happened that
that you felt that this activity has to
be mandatory for all across the board
but i think
i don't yeah i was like i think it was
just their way for the until like you
know everybody go play dares the first
thing you log in so you can see it and
then you might get a halo weapon from
doing it type thing and then like i get
why
but again
unless you're like certain power level
or if you're the light player have a
flag to go
yeah that's exactly so hard but it's to
traverse but it shows the disconnect yes
on the new light experience that's what
this exposed i mean i could understand
a mistake here if they you know put it
this way if it was like what travis said
and
you had a mix right you had some new
lights some you know okay but the new
lights that's that's kind of being
prioritized they're being grouped
together to just jump in there and do
this impossible beat your head against
the wall activity and that to me is just
like wow like that got passed so what
does that say truly about the new light
experience what does that say for a
person that's coming in
this is their first experience this is
what they're going this is literally i'm
uninstalling this game
like yeah what why am i like
why wouldn't they just make the activity
eleven hundred power
right they do that with somebody else
yeah
there's already a cap on how much damage
you can do right and all players who
play every week were already at that oh
way beyond when the activity dropped so
what's the what is the downside of doing
that and the fact that they didn't even
it didn't even occur to them to do that
means that they spend no time thinking
about new life like that's the that's
the way i think about it i would never
not concerned
to hear what the technical reasoning is
right what what happened right that's
well i i just i you have to help me make
sense of this i don't get it like i i'm
not a programmer but how is it that an
activity is forced or the group of new
light players and there's nothing really
they can do to break this loop and
you're just ultimately damaging you're
damaging yourself right your damage your
own product because this is what you
want you want the new guys to come in
experiences so it was just baffling
when you told me that i like i didn't
even think it was real no i mean
what i saw the hour i was like how was
that happening i didn't get explained to
me as well it's like the
the fact that
veterans right now
are putting on capes and masks yeah to
go see
superheroes and theirs of eternity for
these people we're like saving cats from
burning buildings right now and there's
an initiative
yo if you do it yo emblem's coming out
for you thank you for your service thank
you my stuff
like like what is what's happening
what's happening guys i'm trying to be
this i just somebody mentioned it as
well as like uh i think it was new red
like
uh
one of them the fact that there's
champions in here
they don't have champions
you can't get mods for that you have no
champion mods
they're probably trying to shoot a
barrier he's putting up a wall and
they're like why can't i beat this guy
it's like the champion's got them up
against the wall you ain't leaving this
activity
override
what is happening what's happening guys
that's all like you know what
if i was playing the most difficult
activity of my life
like an 1100 level guardian just get
destroyed by these 50 powerful things
the last thing that i would want
is the super sarcastic
super like
dude he's like he's like joking and i'm
like
dying here i'm like suffering like read
the room bunji like this is this is my
vietnam and you're here like cracking
jokes at me like that's the worst
combination possible
[Music]
without for the loot for the new lights
man i i couldn't believe it this was
bro i i didn't believe when you sent me
that that i was true i was like when it
finally sunk in
and then today i actually logged and i
was like can i because i hear actually i
checked reddit more and more people are
not finding them which in theory is good
but like until this gets fixed like
this is one of those points where like
until this gets fixed
they should i don't like
i don't know i don't know what you this
needs fixed like literally asap like i
don't know how hard it is but like this
is priority like one because or you do
what final fantasy did and when you
couldn't log in they literally stopped
selling the game
right like that's one of those points
where it's like hey can you guys like
take this off the pages for a little
while because people buy in this game
are not like literally do that for like
a week if like hey whatever week or two
for the patch we're not selling it until
we have this fixed that would be that
moment for them to say but that's i mean
that's the thing it's like if you buy
destiny right now
and that's what you log into you're like
steam can i get a refund the horse is
not pleased well exactly like that's
kind of one of those weird
that's one of those weird moments where
it's like they need to like
i i don't know how they're going to try
and spin that one in a twap but i'm sure
it's going to be some cute language from
dmg like passing the word along
destiny is free and that's the thing
they almost need to pull it down from
the stores like as destiny is free
but
don't say that
don't don't
say that you know
but i mean so this is a
like if that's your one experience that
free person's not now not going to buy
it
exactly and the other thing is that
how much a thing costs has nothing to do
with how good it is
there are things that cost a lot of
money
that are terrible and there are things
that are free that are great apex
legends is a free game it's an
incredibly well developed video game and
i just
saying destiny is free as an as like a
hand away for anything oh don't be mad
it's free it's like okay well it's not
free when it comes to your time and it
free is no excuse for bad game design
it's no excuse this is a huge miss on
bungie's part like
huge you know i love them
yeah
i just got to try this doom eternal dlc
for destiny
yeah like bro that may as well be facing
off marauders everywhere you look
because you imagine booting up like
what's the strongest boss in dark souls
like could you imagine you're like
construction
oh no
no no it's like at the ball's point
is just prime example
way harder than dark souls
prime example start of like sakura which
you know it's not a big deal you're not
meant to beat like any of those type of
games usually you're not say meant to
beat that first guy you would think this
is that but then you have to reboot and
you're just stuck in the same loop
you can't get out of that like the guy
oh he's supposed to kill me and i'm just
supposed to move on with the story or
something right why am i still here this
is bad yeah
listen i it's funny it's hilarious i'm
dying to know i am going to be reading
that 12 with the finest comb i want to
know the technicality
what happened here because i i it's the
funniest thing i it's a painful and
egregious it is absolutely hilarious
that this has happened and the fact that
there is an initiative going on that
people are literally suiting up and
putting on masks and putting on capes to
save these people are i think it's it's
absolutely hilarious i think it's alive
so yeah so this was the entertaining
part of the day yeah
that was
so i mean it's just like
and we've talked about that before it's
like if you want to make the if you want
more people into the game
if you want to grow
like they're so worried about trying to
build content for the players they have
but i don't like and they do really
great marketing well if one of those
little marketing videos hits you gotta
have the new player have a decent
experience and that's one of those
things again
the new light experience if it's banger
with new light for something we don't
even know about
right then that would be finally a time
but it's like uh i think even skillop
will do like his
uh top 10 or yeah it was games of the
year one of his was destiny
for him
because he lives in it and he plays it
all the time but he also was like i
don't recommend this if you aren't
playing it right now
um one of his is like hey it's like i
live in a plate all the time it's like
so of course it's like right now it's
like great storytelling one of the best
games of the year david by the way with
the 999 super chat thank you very much
not salute seriously thank you um but
like the fact that he put it in the list
with all the other games that he was
playing yet on the other side
he also said don't buy it
because it's like i can't tell you now
is a good time to get into it but if you
have been enjoying it it's in a good
place but let's get that's a weird
sentence
let's get to the elephant in the room
it's just like
historically because of this the nature
of this game live service ever evolving
destiny content vault
how can they i'm not making excuses for
them but like how can they truly have a
starting off point
for the new light to make it easy like i
don't know what they they've kind of
painted themselves in the corner it's
not
our fault and we that's for them to
figure out it's their game you'd figure
it out it's also not a good idea you you
don't want to put yourself in a
situation where
your your player base only has
opportunities to get smaller
right right yeah you don't have a way to
bring in new stuff like if you're if
it's just it's getting smaller it means
that your game has an expiration date
because either your players are going to
get fed up and leave or they're going to
die in teddy's face right like he's
going to be playing until he's dead so
that's his
spot with that i want to know how they
tackle that how do you
because clearly we remember we thought
shaw han in the cosmos room remember oh
yo this is it they're doing it
and
not so much right not still
not the ideal onboarding experience and
i don't know what to tell new players so
it feels like every
expansion oh no this is the new new way
you do it this is the new new way yeah
new lights get on do this do that and
it's easy
but as if we find out you know it
there's still there's still holes
there's still warts there's still
problems and that is a challenge they
got to figure out somehow
especially if like what driver said they
wanna you want that pyramid base to be
the widest right and you want them to
jump there that's what so i don't know
you gotta see what they're gonna do
yeah i just i mean we had to talk about
that one because it's just like cycling
through everywhere but i was like i
don't even it just brings up as you said
it brings up more issues than anything
else because you have to ask
how does it get through
enough people's hands that a new light
player gets screwed that bad and it was
it was even worse today like for the one
time i saw guys like cool we can help
him maybe if we get him to the end of
that then you know maybe i'll get this
emblem bailed before we even made the
first little jump so i'm like i don't
for one don't even know if i'm gonna get
the emblem which i don't care i was just
trying to see if i could help but two
that guy just had a crappy experience
i'm like that's that's the bad example
so
yeah i don't know i don't know but
definitely
one of the fun moments in destinies
these are the movies i want to know what
the emblem going to look like
unbelievable
they better look like the red cross or
something just like yeah
yeah i want to know what that envelope
is going to be because we had some fun
ones we had the the one laser tag yes
lens laser tag we had the the wolves
running wild with lord of wars
yeah this is up there this is up there i
but
moment
was like wow okay
well i was like there's not a whole lot
else going on this week but i wanted to
ask you guys with regards to witch queen
main topics what is the one you hope to
see
next week
and then what do you hope is the longest
twab topic
it was the trash what'd you think
so our question the question is what do
you want to see and then we talk about
in the 12 next week yeah what's your
what's the first thing in which queen
that you want them to open the box on
and you peek inside and then what do you
think is going to be the longest swab
topic over the course of the next five
or six weeks
honestly i i kind of hope they don't
tell us anything
personally i i sort of so i felt like i
honestly know that sentiment yeah yes
yeah
well no it's it's not even that it's
like bungie should be lauded for
its amazing community management and and
how much they go above and beyond
personally i think
talking to your fans every week as long
as they do is way too often like it's
that's so much communicating
um yeah it's like that's got to be a
drain like the fact that they are coming
up with topics every week and kind of
like that's just supernatural in terms
of like their commitment to that
um but i'm sort of
i kind of don't want them to pull it
back too far like i'm not like e where i
i don't want them to spoil
you know the reveal
yeah it's totally fine just let that go
the stuff that happens on the first
mission of the game that everybody's
gonna play it's like the first thing
that happens
who cares um
but i i do think that um
i do think that sometimes they over
share and over prepare us i kind of
don't really want to know exactly what
to expect from the new destinations or
exactly what to expect from the new
raid or you know i want to know stuff
like when it's going to drop yeah that's
important
when is
really all the stuff i want to know is
like when is the new sandbox gonna be
here uh when is the raid gonna drop give
us like a timeline for like when we
should be logged on
and tell me what other balances you're
doing before uh the new content comes
out but in terms of like them talking
about weapon crafting just wait i'm
talking about the glaives wait them
giving us more trailers wait like i all
that stuff i kind of just hope that they
they keep it in the black box but uh i
know they won't i'm sure we're gonna get
a couple more trailers i'm sure we're
gonna get uh an in-depth look on the new
location and the new patrol zone or
whatever and it's gonna be i'm gonna be
like damn it i wish i didn't see that
but uh yeah
yeah i mean
i i think one thing that
we kind of
know from them is like
i know it's not trailer time just yet
but
we know when that comes
it's on that's one thing they do well
without a shadow it curse of osiris
trailer was fire
like like one thing when it comes to
marketing and getting that i'm not even
worried about um
you know to your question what i want to
see
first
um
is it too early to talk about sandbox i
feel like we just talked about sandbox
they just really called the 30th sandbox
stuff but i mean yeah that would be so
the stuff that
let me jump in because i'm might list
off a few things here let's go the
things that i am happy to see
void 3.0
an explanation of how the switch is
going to work
how
different supers are going to function
is it just going to be a drop down and
you pick them uh aspects and fragments
you're gonna be getting those from maybe
icora on this one because she seems like
she would you know be a void type
however that works
that would be you know what is the menu
system gonna like those screenshots
that's the stuff i wanna see
and that i'm okay seeing as travis said
i don't want
them to explain
here's the six person activity where you
don't like i don't need to know that
type of stuff granting the six-person
activity
it's a thing it's fine we'll we'll get
that one and then the seasonal activity
as well we'll get another six person
activity two things travis can be less
thrilled about yeah
six person activities are just like
go from one to another yeah dude just
like not like the single one so okay
question do you guys think it's going to
be a trailer or vidoc
i think it's time for a vita
i feel it's been a minute man it's been
a while i don't know if they're going to
do vitox anymore cj left yeah well
i kind of know too much
yeah you know a lot
you're not right what was the last vital
we got i felt like it was beyond light
one i'm pretty sure we got a big one we
got a big one we got the which no what's
green they had a valley right up the
announcement they had a big one remember
it was kind of like yo we're here and oh
they did they did yeah that was huge
yeah okay so that was yeah that was the
one with like everybody coming up on
stage talking apart going back down oh
that was during the reveal event yeah
yeah available
huge it was you um yes that's right i
mean
we're right on this is a big expansion
we're in the precipice but to to
travis's point like that maybe the
finals may have already been i guess
done kind of done yeah and and to
travis's point because of the pandemic
that might not be the cadence anymore
right because what that was just
literally getting people in the room and
and doing our stuff so
yeah it is i'm curious about the rollout
cadence
leading up to february the february date
how they're gonna handle that because
they got we do know there is a cadence
of getting that hype train
rolling
before the kind of weeks and then the
other thing is to be honest like
when are we getting our um
our uh what you call it uh marisol
cybertune eventual betrayal moment okay
so that has to be february
uh i think that'll be separate and i
think before that we'll get one more
trailer and it'll spoil something else
that we wish we didn't know that's like
big like it'll it'll like show like mars
as a patrol zone or something like that
where we're like oh okay that's
confirmed that's what i think that's
what they'll do right
yeah i was like i guess on like the
epilogue for this season i think i was
talking with chad or somebody about this
one enough like
uh because i actually had jarv we uh he
jumped in and we ran like a four-man
legend
uh dares of eternity just to kind of
check the four-man box
um so we ran that one we just sat and
chatted for a while
so we were talking me uh new rad and
blackwings and then jarv like
you guys know him um we chatted for a
long time just trying to figure out and
it's like
his bet was on
uh february 1st
because he said february 1st there is
like some in real life there's some
excuse me
astrological alignment thing happening
between planets or something so we
thought that might be an actual cool
thing to tie the
alignment of the ley lines up in the
game with that would be kind of a cool
way to tie those two together
he said that one if it's not that date
then my guess is obviously the week
right after the eighth because then it's
literally two weeks before and that's
kind of their two-week cadence so it's
like one of those two places
basically was
where i would imagine and it would make
no sense like if we log in on tuesday
and we get it then we're just like five
weeks away and then you have the little
lull before you get to which queen so i
think they're the sabbath crystal is
breaking open whatever happens has to be
close to
witch queen if it's too far away it
doesn't make too much sense um
like forcado did actually say that was
the stream back over for which queen but
the vidoc for beyond light he said it
was a month before launch
so we do still have potential for a
vidoc in
you know the next couple of weeks of
this month could fit easily in there
um final trailer like marketing promos
that type of stuff will be you know that
final week trailer as travis said
showing me something i don't really want
to see
so basically the e-bars don't want to
see a trailer yeah i should probably
skip it
i'll go in blind but he can't because he
i can't because
i have to come here man i have to spoil
stuff for myself sometimes i'm like damn
it
so
probably that type of thing and then
like twab so like next week for kado
it's like it's like kind of think i saw
this too dmg said next week's trob will
be lighter
it's not going to have like a big you
know weapon crafting dump in it or
anything like that so next week will be
lighter
and dave i got a question for you all
too i got another question for you the
next one would be 13th so you got 20th
27th third 10th and 17th you have five
more twabs after next week to after give
us whatever we want like however much
you want to cover
that's too many yes a lot yeah question
random um
when do you think we get the next big
what we call them this the state of the
the state of the luke
where did we get the statement
if there is a vidoc it would be in there
because the vidoc they put together is
like the interviews like you know the
screenshots of monitors that people
break down that stupid crazy stuff like
not the actual twitch stream but like
here's the like
14 minute video from bungie i'm gonna
get that yeah if you're gonna get that
one and if you know four cup if it's you
know falls in that month before a couple
of weeks but i mean the other one i'm
talking about
you're saying but that's you that's
usually their move though right they
release a vidoc and then right after the
vidoc comes out they do like a twab that
has like a
oh
i'm talking
and generally
where
those states tend the cadence tends to
be
they break
bad news
first true prior to a big experience to
let you know but this is why the game's
going to be better y'all
i'll just really tend to get i want to
know i always feel like
i did that i was like almost feeling
like the bad news came this week
with the blue lights
outside what did you say with the what
where we well they announced everything
they're vaulting
oh what was that i mean that's been out
for a little bit but yeah the the year
five vaulting that stuff's been out for
a bit yeah
yeah no honestly i like reiterated this
week though they like said like this
this is the stuff specifically that's
coming out okay
i haven't seen that specifically but not
saying it's not there but i don't
you want the juice honestly like i feel
like a state of the game has come at
like
you know spring after we get an
expansion as i think we're before really
yeah i feel like those have been i don't
think those have preceded large
expansions this close
it feels like those have come either in
down times or in other i feel like
they've been
farther like either i don't feel like
like in the goal of this next season is
where i feel like they always break some
bad news no i'm not saying they won't
break bad news in a trois but i don't
see a state of the game coming
right before witch queen launches
because they probably want all of
because they wouldn't want to take away
from witch queen at this point i think
which queen would launch
you know you'll have the seasonal stuff
going we'll get the cadence of that then
when you get to the low point in the
season
okay
state of the game last year wasn't
chosen
so like basically you're saying
your prediction is post witch queen
pre little ex little season
before the next little season comes up
yeah it would either be a preamble to
season 17
or like you know once season 17 counting
against the point you say they gave a
state of the game when people that's
what i was actually going to say at one
point i was like right now everybody's
too hyped for it so it's like they
needed yeah
i just know it's coming this year i just
want to know i'm trying to get win
because they always do it because
they're going to drop all right guys
now we're we're bringing the sunset yup
yup hey bro
boy
i can't and then all the old
yeah
we kind of already got one with the uh
with the lengthy here's what crucible is
going to look like thing right yeah
yeah
yeah i mean that was pretty pretty 2022
when's the 2022 one i don't think it's
coming this year i don't think it's
coming anytime soon
okay so you feel he's prediction for the
record yep when summer when you think
well i gotta figure out dates february
if you go february march april may
maybe may maybe other the down time of
16
or a few weeks into 17 once it's kind of
rolling
gotcha
addiction when people are chomping
september when they also announce that
uh
uh light fall is gonna be fall of 2023
yeah
they might just they might just announce
an 18-month model yeah going forward
that's that's one thing i'm actually
very curious about when we log in
how long is season 16
are they going to do as you said i think
you said it last week actually it's like
3 3
3 3 3
however long it takes to get that one
ready or are they going to go longer
seasonal type things as well because we
also get arc 2.0 or r 3.0 solar 3.0 i
wonder if they need more time to build
those things as well so longer seasons
might give the devs more time if they
like yeah that's kind of always the
thing it's like log in and see how long
is this season gonna be we logged into
this one it's like a hundred days and
we're like all right
mm-hmm
yeah
it's it's gonna be interesting
i've been wanting to talk about that for
a couple of last words but i finally
remember it i was like yeah i'm curious
what you guys think of that because it
it it it's become a routine it's become
a tradition it's going to stay on
occasion we get yeah that big state of
the game
some level of bad news is dropped
the community flips usually prior to the
news and then they have to explain
themselves in this lengthy
you know
heart to heart talk with that with the
base as to why and i'm curious to see
what when that happens because it's
always interesting when they when they
do that
so
what was the ques the original question
which i feel like we fell far off of
sorry um
oh yeah do you what do you want to see
in the toilet yeah what do you want what
do you want to see yeah okay so if the
next week is light and maybe next week's
gonna be like here's the schedule of
twabs like this week's gonna cover this
this week because they've done that
before too like tell us the weekly
schedule of twelves
right what do you what's what do you
want to see the most like what do you
want them to break down in some detail
what what would you like to see in the
12. i don't even care if bigger or not
it's going to be light i mean if they're
already setting the stage it's going to
be light it's going to explain what the
hell happened to new lights give us if
possible uh road map not a full maybe
exact dates but like
when do you plan on getting the train
rolling like when these you know expect
this this okay let me let me rephrase
the question
what what swab are you the most excited
for what twab topic over the next five
or six weeks
is the one that you're waiting for like
when you're like hey i see this is in
this date i'm tuning it like you know i
know yours is generally sandbox like but
yeah what are you looking forward to the
most topic was
either be honest the conclusion of this
damn season this season too damn long
when is it over
please saboteur trick mara so we can get
this going that like duke complete the
seance
complete the damn seance like i'm sick
of seeing them seven six whatever them
tekkens
finish it first
this season is the long i mean wait they
got a delay
oh god it's just painful just like i
want this thing okay already
that's what i need yes
so you wanna your biggest thing right
now is to know when this is in you don't
wish queen's just gonna be a thing
okay so threads if travis is right and
we have an 18-monther
for the next year ish whatever you want
to call him now
the year of bunge uh vagabonda was like
16 weeks 17 17 week season 18 week
season 19 week season
depending okay so would you rather go 3
33 or like three four f however long
and have somewhat shorter
seasons or is this big one at the end
what you prefer or is this one killing
you if they do that again this is
killing me i'm not gonna lie like
there's a part of me that loves the fact
that i was i'm away and i'm playing my
other games i'm not going to lie and say
i'm not yeah but
to your point i'm i'm going to piggyback
you e
this
system is systematically killing the
momentum of the narrative it is
literally destroying it you have come to
a screeching halt and now it's like i
forgot right so it's just like we got to
get that going again in this case we
giving them a slight pass they did delay
it we understand that the delay plays a
factor but they've got to figure this
out because you can't just do
that's like even the walking dead when
they do a mid-season finale it's what
most two weeks three weeks or whatever
then you're back in the mix this is how
long when was the last
oh she's a little beat crap
jesus well i mean yeah
you know it was what like the thing is
i
i think i think that's a problem with
the narrative decisions they made though
not really the format because if they
had finished the story put a cap on it
and then been like all right now right
before witch queen comes out we're going
to do something else that kicks off that
story it's going to be this problem the
reason we're upset is because they
didn't finish the story they were
telling right and then they said yeah
we'll finish it you know right before
which green comes out and that's like
the frustration so yeah i think it's i
think they could have avoided this if
they would have just given us some kind
of satisfying conclusion to the story
they were telling
and then
not giving us any expectation that there
was going to be more story this season
it's kind of just the way they've been
doing it that's irritating
yeah i was like i've probably been
harping on this one for weeks now but
it's like i'm at the point to where you
have i know
but like just going forward for the
future seasons
especially if it is like vagabondo said
if they do have
you cut out bees muted i touched my mic
oh yeah there you go yourself
um
if which queens year or however long it
takes to get to lightfall if they want
to do a longer seasonal model
then as you said it's like the waiting
for the final piece makes it worse so
it's like you know as you said you want
to play the other games cool just don't
have this little bug in the back of my
brain that's killing me to know i just
want to know what the last thing was
right just give it to me and then you
can have the people play the eight weeks
have the fun
drop something cool people come back but
don't have just the anticipation of that
and it never lives up to the
anticipation that's the bigger problem
we're gonna get this thing and it's
gonna be like cool now just give me a
witch queen
yeah
yeah i kind of i kind of want them to
continue to do this model personally
the reason because
i do think it's helpful to have a longer
gap both i i assume for their own
production sake right because they're
preparing for this big expansion and
they need more time
two to account for potential additional
delays which i think there probably will
inevitably be right and if you try to
control the weeks artificially there's a
there's eventually going to be some sort
of break in that flow anyway
and also because
i kind of like to have one long break
per year where it's sort of like on
hiatus
they tend to stuff all of their seasonal
events in there like
festival of the lost and donning both
happened this season right like there's
just like a lot of kind of end-of-year
seasonal stuff that they do that would
feel a little odd if it was happening in
the middle of seasons or like right at
the beginning
of a season if they're doing that old
model um so yeah i kind of think i kind
of think it's okay if they want to do it
this way i just think that to cog and to
your point e like
the story that they decided to tell
is irritating it's because the break is
so long they just should have just told
they finished telling the story and then
had no justification for why it takes so
long it's not like any of us are
looking at the destiny story and going
oh why does this stuff not make sense we
know that it's a game and some of the
story beats don't really make sense
right we know that they're
we know that they're all justifying her
still being in this crystal cocoon
because they have to wait it's not like
any of us are like oh yeah well that
makes sense that's been in the lore for
years that right you have to be in a
crystal cocoon for six months before you
can pop out like that's gotta turn this
butterfly warm off yeah yeah
yeah it's it's like just just drop the
act like just tell us the story you're
gonna tell and then we'll ignore the
six-month break and pretend like it all
makes sense chronologically you know
well i mean like you don't have to be
six months in canon right right
yeah that's kind of the thing it's like
you picture and granted i've never
played final fantasy like 14 but in
walker just dropped it's not like people
were waiting for the final chapter of
the previous expansion to like finish up
right like two weeks before and walker
see how the previous one ends it's like
we've been waiting three years for that
crap what are you doing to be like
that doesn't happen in other games and
the seasonal cadence would be the same
way i think so it's like
i think we're
i think depending on the schedule now
forecast did say something interesting
because they said in the previous state
of the game last year they want to keep
the quarter one window for their dlcs
because it's healthier for their team
that's fine which would then mean it's
just you know we're back to an annual
release schedule which if that's
something they can
keep up with then you know more power to
them i just have i have zero confidence
that in a year from the witch queen
we're gonna be playing lightfall that
seems crazy to me it does to me too and
that's the thing it's like i don't know
how big the team is i don't know what
they they're you know bandwidth is for
putting out content
but again is that the time where they're
like has that been in the works for like
two i don't know
it's hard to know but i think
yeah obviously we're just all champing
at the bit
um
we are you know can i say one more thing
about the story that's been annoying me
sure ironically
ironically the one guy who could have
saved us from sabbath's deception with
osiris is brother vance the guy that we
hated yeah
we all we all we treated him so poorly
and look look what happened he would
have saved us the entire year
i said brother vance got murdered right
did he get murdered uh what did he do
something on mercury where i think he
died he died i think he died like
something when the ship came in or he
was just gonna stay there i don't know
yeah he's toast i'm pretty sure so
well as we hit a nice little tight two
hours we managed to fill two hours of
speculation if nothing else and uh stuff
over the course of a time when destiny's
still not got a lot going on
but tomorrow will be a light or next
week will be a light swab and then it's
probably going to be
bigger from there um once i kind of get
the guest schedule ironed out you guys
will see those coming up as well so
going to be with at least one more
person here on the show with us joining
soon so stay tuned for those times uh
but as we wrap it up um anything else
you guys want to cover any quick uh jabs
you want to get in before we go
travis
why do you assume i've got jabs
i can't quite imagine why that would be
just like my go-to for you that's so
weird oh he walked into the vex gate
that's right
that's right there you go
so yeah i don't have any quick jabs um
i'm thanks for watching the show
everyone tell your friends about the
show maybe they'll watch it and then
stop being friends with you afterwards
um
uh yeah you can follow me on on twitter
at ty guy travis
you can read my reviews previews and
articles on ign.com and i'm really
looking forward to this year i'm i'm
really excited about witchcreen and
having the opportunity to review it i
think the best thing about reviewing a
game you really love is that
you know it's gonna force you to play
it because sometimes you're like oh i
don't know if i don't have enough
lifetime to do it but if you can turn to
your significant other and be like hey
this is work honey i'm sorry i need to
play
it's like a weird feeling it's a
beautiful big feeling so
um yeah i'm very excited for it um i
also want to give a shout out to bitcast
[Music]
our
our show
sunday mornings at uh 8 a.m pacific i
think is when i agreed to wake up
we talk about lots of different stuff
sometimes i convince them to talk about
destiny even when they have no interest
in it um and you can see me and a guy
named ains who is a very stubborn uh but
but bright young man and then also
a um
problem man named dan
i just call him the problem man the
problem man named and i live to throw
bricks up
uh yeah you're like
on top of the apartment besides uh
besides moving those oculus units
i'm out here moving like there's like
there's like people like posting like i
bought oculus because cog told me to and
i'm like that's some influencer where's
your referral code you know i know i'm
like you need to attack incognito oculus
it's been cool to see i i'm very humbled
to see people say that like yo because
of you i i picked it up but i'm like wow
like that that is insane man but yeah
you gotta point to your boss
that's gonna be in the performance
review
look at my units moving units bro how
many years even you didn't move this
year
reading my presentation but now it's
been cool man is seeing everybody get
down and having fun with that so dad
just saw i needed the time off though
the time off i needed it bad i had to
recharge get rest you know doing so many
things
was cool i like that actually these last
words have been kind of light in a way
so it's been kind of cool just to kind
of just
shoot it and just not not even go too
crazy i know once we ramp up it's on but
i needed it so for that duke has been
fine so get back into that and then iop
returns this sunday will be tell aims
we will be at 1 pm eastern we'll give
him the space because he's like dave bro
you guys were loving that we moved to 11
a.m eastern we're back to our 1 p.m king
and attic with this day i don't know if
they don't have to curse at me no more
for getting up earlier i'm sorry when do
you guys have like win nfl seasons like
hot dabby
what time are you starting the podcast
easter egg
easter when nfl is hot and heavy we're
at 11 a.m eastern so that's right week
one of the new nfl season that's where
we go 11. 11 a.m is early
yeah
okay
because the game started at 1 pm the
gamers bro haven't you ever seen the
show up at noon
i was gonna be like grow up
saturday night playing whatever three
four in the morning you know wiping the
crust out of his eye the next one do you
understand if you go to bed at four in
the morning you could still get up at 10
o'clock and get six hours of sleep
that's more than i get half the time
four four o'clock in the morning it
might be early for him
that's what i'm saying you might want to
like it's one day of the week man like
just you got you got obligations figured
it was bro gamers bro i've seen him on
the podcast too he won't even turn on
his camera because it's 11 am and he i
went to yeah i got 8 a.m
like what what happened i have no
empathy for that i've burned both into
the candle just yeah sorry
i don't i'll relate to feedback but i'm
like it's one day lord addict he doesn't
have good impulse control i mean
the boy's been named for a reason i mean
fair but i'm like
somebody call that boy and be like
you're online at three o'clock i'm
telling the
the power good shut you off
i'm gonna cut you off
if this xbox is on after 2 am on a
sunday it will shut down until after
iron lord's podcast
is going to give him family control
iop family control you can you can only
exchange your hours you can only play 10
hours a day
yeah we'll be back man sunday be back 1
p.m eastern and homie forte boom will be
on so we'll just talk about what's going
on a lot of stuff going on in the
industry oh
forgot dude we got to say this guys rest
in peace e3
oh going basically online yeah so we
gotta find out gcx what are you doing
are you still going on i mean just this
year though right they're still planning
a physical return
and um what's your man uh
what's that guy named fluffer whatever
mike fudder mike fudder said it's an
excuse they were already canning it
they're they're using omni uh not that
omnicom is not serious yeah i'll read
the tweet because i got it ready for my
notes already for iop he said when they
said e3 shifts to online event only
because of omnicorn concerns that was
the official statement by the usa my
father said this is spin i've heard from
sources in mid-november before
omnicron's emergence at the end of that
month that the esa has abandoned their
dates for the um the los angeles
convention center and then
schreier put out a treat a tweet prior
to that saying yeah he's heard it's the
end i mean i'm i'm not surprised
like i mean
things go set i was like it is like it
is the end of an era legitimately but i
mean the writing's been on the wall in
the past like year and a half the way
everything's been done
too many companies don't want to go rent
a space pay all the money to the usa
right like all like if anything they
would if things get back to a reasonable
space microsoft could do their like i
can't remember what theirs was called
because i didn't feel like i went to one
what were there like on location once
the fan fast stuff not even not even
that but i don't know either way but
like you know sony playstation
experience they could do that one or
whatever and then if expo like you could
do that type of thing where you could
get tickets and go to a microsoft thing
if they want to do their one-time event
kind of like a blizzcon i could see
those types of things may be happening
if things get back to somewhat
reasonableness but like right now it
doesn't make sense and then the e3
people finally had a reason to bail and
they just don't see a reason to go back
i honestly think that's a mistake i
think that
the great thing about e3 is the whole
industry comes together to celebrate
games as one body and i think that whole
segmentation of people like going and
doing their own things and living in a
silo is like you don't really see other
industries doing that
you know like the movie industry doesn't
have like separate oscars for like
universal and then so you know separate
ones for for yeah it's all segmented
this last point jason's right yes
he said
it comes back
let's let me just this one this is the
one that hit me hard he goes uh five
hours ago after the mike photo tweet
that i read sounds like e3 is all but
dead can someone come up with an excuse
to go everybody go to l.a in june then
he says by the way i 100 believe flutter
fish is reporting that the esa gave up
on e3 three days ago over otherwise
there would have been uh dates on the
website over the pr fluff piece that hit
today no way this is a knee-jerk
reaction to omnicron it's e3 throwing in
the towel officially
wow i mean i believe it i just i think
it it's unfortunate because i think e3
did have a valuable
place in the industry and yeah it has a
bunch of problems like it was over
priced esa wasn't always the best
organization to host it and
people had been pulling out for years
like ea doing ea play and stuff but if
you've ever been to e3 there's really
nothing like having everyone together
and just like
everyone there loves games and you see
people with nintendo talking to people
from playstation and you know
they're exchanging tips and they're
making connections and you know it i'm
i'm really just going to be
missing i'm just happy i i did go to a
few and
those are some of the best experiences
i've ever had you know it's just a
fraternity but
like you said the centralized location
and everyone the every bit of the movers
and shakers of the industry
yeah it's it's
shout out to teddy the ign war rooms
he's one of the best
yeah yeah honestly covering e3 sucks i i
almost killed myself
yeah you kill yourself but it is so much
fun
i'm really going to miss it and the last
thing i'll say for the rest of peace is
um
literally iron podcast wouldn't be where
it would be without e3 like that is a
big jumping off point for us going out
there growing our channel boots to the
ground
i met ryan in the flesh i met so many
people and spawned so many relationships
that really helped iop get to where it
is so i'm just curious to last what i'll
say is i'm curious about gcx now i mean
clearly i'm free to go gcx if you're
doing it
i got no things in the way now
it's got a little extra space there
hey gc accent because i was mad at you
you did it around e3 but
what's the deal if you if there's if
there's any state that won't cancel an
event because of kovid
that's the only thing that gives that
thing a little bit of dope
triple boosted
i'm ready i got my 5g plus plus triple
boost i got my wi-fi
i got everything in me let's go
let me stop
but yeah we'll see let's see if
yeah
well for me it seems like i'll be
working on this inscription on weird
hours
uh see how that one goes working through
backlog stuff in between i've got some
bigger ones
and then i'm still just like dreading
that week of february because like i
want to play through horizon zero dawn
that's like what kind of was one of my
biggest ones oh the screenshots bro you
seen the new stuff oh dude it looks
absolutely amazing i just can't rush
that game in four days
and if i start it and then play
witch queen and then elden rings gonna
call my my off time's gonna go elden
ring so i can't even start
i'll just probably see review scores for
horizon and know that i'll get to it
later but yeah my backlog i got a couple
things that i wanted to work on picked
up a couple little ones and then
horizon's probably the big one that i'd
like to get in kind of also want to do
dark souls one just just like uh
get me back in the mode for elden ring
kind of play one of the less friendly
ones if possible even though i hear
two's the hardest actually
but yeah other than that i think um yeah
poor one out for e3 you guys know where
to find all the awesome people find
travis on his twitter or go you know
refresh those ign articles for some
views get that man some love that's
right that's right iron lords podcast
cognito apparently go by a quest drop uh
just hey lord cognito sent me makes you
get that referral code
yeah
i was told this did come with a twenty
dollar coupon um
you might get a little poster of lord
cognito himself
he's got to be mid flex though like i
can't get just the normal one i got to
get i'm putting mine into a body pillow
so you got to get the you got to get the
flex poster for cog and then for me to
find me twitter twitch playing destiny
playing other random weird trippy games
inscription's odd and i'll just say that
um yeah should be should be a fun few
weeks coming up and we know next week is
where it's just gonna start to get a
little crazier so ramp up chad you guys
have been amazing if you enjoyed the
show if you got friends share it with
them drop a like on the video leave us a
good review on itunes on spotify um i
tend to throw a little question on there
actually for spotify you can actually
drop a question into the podcast i think
i did one last week so i want to look
real fast
um what is your favorite year of destiny
2 we had 14 votes so again spotify is
not gonna get too many votes because
people don't see it uh 21 was year four
21 was year five which was forsaken
nobody voted for shadow keep and then 57
57 voted for this year
yeah so really yep that's surprising to
me
so i will probably put another random
one out there so if you guys do listen
on spotify feel free to check that one
out but thank you guys very much for
episode number 179
january 6th ages 20. out to e
shout out to e he got retweeted by joe
oh yeah shout out guys
say that before that's right he's a big
star blackburn bending the knee to
ebontis
bruh yes wow the legendary black firm i
was very i was kind of beside myself
trying to figure out what to say to that
one but i was just like
it's been a while since that video came
out and he's just like that i was like
oh thanks for using the guide i'm like
i'm sorry who said that tweet
so
no he's yeah i was like send him a quick
dm and just said thank you um he said
you know
yeah seemed very nice just quick
response but like he actually responded
to the dm as well so
nope that was that kind of magic moment
that was that was surprising so magic i
had a magic moment and then the lustre
got taken all away from it so i was like
i'm watching i saw ryan mccaffrey's
timeline and he put something up i guess
uh john cena has like a new movie coming
out uh peacemaker on hbo show yeah so
he's talking about it promoting it from
ign all right cool and he's oh wow
you know um john cena is following me i
didn't even know that then he gets he
checks and then i i guess john cena
really has like a really follow back
kind of policy so i went to go check
yo justin is following me too
following you oh man that's amazing
check if john cena is following
everybody like
at this point if you interact you've
crossed paths he's following you at some
point but i just thought it was
absolutely hilarious because i thought i
was like wow that's so cool he's so
special with it i'm like oh wow i'm
special too but i'm like who else are
you following john cena
did you see
20 000 followers he probably got a lot
did you see on the other side where
gordon ramsay was like what is a twitch
did you see the clip
yes hilarious actually
i've watched master chef just because i
like cooking and kind of seeing like
amateurs like learn that type of stuff
and his new one next level chef and that
was like they're introducing all the new
chefs for the year and his new show and
i was like
that's the clip
but yeah then somewhere like him he like
changed his name on twitter to like
gordon ramsay who doesn't know what
twitch is or something like that there
was this like meme he had for a day
which was hilarious so i was saying that
he says he saw cena following some
people from twitch told me okay maybe
that was it oh shout out the black ronin
happy birthday if that's your boy named
brother that happy birthday i see a lot
of people saying happy birthday to him
in the chat you're looking forward to
eye of peace okay us a little real
salute good to see you in here as always
okay well long intros out of the way
thank you all very much um all of you
guys who showed up today we will be back
next week hopefully you enjoyed the show
but for this time being for this episode
it has been
the last word the last word the last
words
[Applause]
all right you guys we are out of here
we'll see you later